this is jocko podcast number 272 with
echo charles
and me jocko willink good evening echo
good evening
so when i worked
with seal leaders
and and then on top of that interacted
with leaders from
the army and from the marine corps
sometimes things went great and
sometimes they didn't and if there was a
problem
between leaders
between leaders between people between
troops 99
of the time when i would pull the thread
on that problem at the end of that
thread would be
ego
you'd find it all the time i'd find it
all the time and when i retired from the
navy and i started working with
leadership in civilian companies no
shock i found the same thing
when when leaders can't get along
when when they can't find a solution
when they can't even move forward
despite
having a common goal when i'm working
with companies and i pull the thread on
that problem
i find the same thing i find
ego and egotistical leaders
scream and they yell and they get
emotional and they would rather
lose they would rather lose than admit
that they're wrong
they would actually rather die in some
cases than admit that they're wrong
and and if you think that that's an
exaggeration
history is full of leaders
military leaders that died
clinging to their plan
even in the face of their own death or
worse the deaths of their troops
all because of their ego now look
of course it's a dichotomy
we know that not all ego is bad you need
ego to push you and drive you and make
you want to win and that's great
but over inflated ego is the
root of a vast majority of problems that
people
and leaders face
and as i look at the
divisiveness in america right now
the people that are screaming
from the extreme ends of the political
spectrum
when i listen to what they're saying
and why they're saying it i try and
figure out where this is coming from
when i pull the thread on all that
screaming
and all that anger yes once again
i find ego
because if you if you
think you're right about everything
if you think that you're right about
everything that means everybody else is
wrong
and if you think that you know
everything then that means no one else
can know anything
and if your ego is so big and you think
you're so smart
why would you even have to listen to
anybody else
because you already have it figured out
why not just scream at them to shut up
and you gotta watch out especially when
if if if someone is saying something
that actually makes some kind of sense
and it hurt your ego
then just scream louder
and when i look around and i see people
that are screaming and not listening
that's what i see i see ego
and sometimes it's driven by insecurity
insecurity that they think there might
be wrong and so then
again what do they do they just scream
louder don't let anyone else talk
shut them up that's what the ego does
that being said there are people out
there today many of whom are humble
people that do listen people that can
have an interactive
conversational exchange with someone
else that might have opposing viewpoints
and they're confident enough in
themselves to actually listen and
discuss
and compromise and change their minds
and learn and grow
and understand and empathize
and those types of people
well they make good neighbors
they make good soldiers they make good
friends they make good human beings
and they make good leaders
and i'm lucky enough to have one of
those people here with us tonight
a soldier a martial artist
a surfer
a former congresswoman a hawaiian
and an american
you might have figured it out tulsi
gabbard
tulsi thanks for joining us aloha the
last time we were together was
on joe rogan's podcast yes
that was fun when was that
i think that was sometime in 2019
were you running yet i was
yeah i was crazy yeah
and um yeah it's been a wild ride it's
been cool
um well it's been cool for me to watch i
know it's not always been cool
i'm thinking like i don't know if cool
is the word i would use
it's always cool for me to look at
someone that's like trying to make
something happen and coming up against
all kinds of obstacles and still
striving forward and pushing forward so
from that perspective it's been cool um
so let's let's kind of like um i always
like to start from the beginning it's
kind of what i like to do so i have a
better
context and understanding of where
someone ends up
because we know more about where they
came from yeah so
let's talk about where you came from how
did you
end up here today it started off where
american samoa
american samoa is where i was born um
i am the did you just suddenly correctly
[Music]
yeah it's i don't
it's just a fact right i feel very
comfortable speaking
i mean obviously i speak all the time
but
words that i don't know how to say i
just do my best and move on
and i i will cover books i've got french
words and german names
and what i just run into total things
that i i just don't know how to say them
and so what i do is i just do my best
and move on and i think i get a
certain level of forgiveness from people
completely i do get tightened up from
time to time
if i really make something awful but
yeah i guess you have to forgive me a
little bit because i just kind of say
what i
what it looks like to me phonetically
and move on
no no judgment whatsoever i however
would get in trouble if i am not
yeah pronouncing my homeland properly if
you say samoa though
like samoa samoan that that's more like
forgivable right now totally like yeah
it's not
that's like the proper way that's like
you use
the proper way yeah but if you don't
it's kind of like okay it's it's way
more forgivable with someone yeah yeah
yeah
yeah okay so it's not a major violation
not at all it's not it's actually not a
violation
right no like really it's not it doesn't
like it's literally it's only people
from samoa who say
is it insulting that i would say samoa
yeah that's a good question a little bit
no
okay so we're good either way yeah
you're good either way all right well
when i went to guam there was people
from samoa there
and we hung out most good people nice
all right so how do you feel everywhere
so
um my mom was born in indiana grew up in
michigan
uh dad born in uh
born in samoa um my grandfather
was in the air force and so he was born
there but he spent the first years of
his life
in hawaii my grandfather was stationed
at hickam
and then um you know moved around a few
other places but ended up growing up
in the panhandle of florida so so wait
so your grandfather was in the in the
air force yeah both
both of my grandfathers on my mom's side
and my dad's side
served uh served in the military that
must have been around world war ii it
was
yeah um so my mom's dad
served in i believe he served in europe
i don't know exactly where
and then but but for a shorter stint
that he didn't spend a career in the
military but my dad's dad did spend his
career uh in the military and
at different times served i think he was
in the army for a little while then he
was in the army air corps then he ended
up in the air force
and um so they both
had completely different upbringings uh
you know my mom grew up in east grand
rapids michigan which was
during that time a very kind of
well-to-do
area in her school there were no
there were no non-white people and so
you know she grew up she's a cheerleader
she was this she kind of had the
all-american upbringing
so she's a white person too she is a
white person
holly as we say in hawaii
which which you know little digression
here people say haole is a derogatory
word but all depends on how you use it
yeah it can go it can go either way
that's sort of like and it can be
it's it can be referred to as an
attitude like i don't care what your
skin color is
it can be used in a derogatory yeah or
it can just be like okay you happen to
be caucasian and
howly but yeah so yes my mom is holly
um based on her skin color and uh
and yeah my dad polynesian grew up
grew up essentially in the south and um
it was so stark their upbringings and
and to hear
both of them tell stories about it
because
you know my dad's going to elementary
school
and he he's told me how like the teacher
asked
asking all the kids okay where are you
from and he raised his hand he's like
i'm from samoa and she said what
somalia are you from africa he's like no
no no samoa
it's you know and that that was it like
all the kids started making fun of him
he's the only kid with brown skin skin
in the class
and uh you know would go out go out in
town and
and and get called get called the n-word
get scolded out of you know the men's
bathroom and told you gotta go use the
colored bathroom
um you know there's no water fountain
you gotta go use the hose in the back
because the water fountain is for whites
only and and so as
he was so confused coming from samoa and
then hawaii
and he's like i mean i'm not i'm not
black i'm
like he he was it was it was at a young
age this kind of
being confronted with racism obviously
but also just
confusion on his part and
that that kind of was the uh
made a huge a huge impact in his in his
formative years in life and
um so fast forward he's going to
college in california mom's going to
university of michigan
they both had summer jobs at yosemite
and which is how they met
and uh that was you know what year that
was
that would have been in the 60s and
maybe they know tilt one of our one of
our
frequent podcast guests john striker
meyer who ended up being a green beret
sog guy in vietnam before he went in the
army
he he went out to yosemite and worked
there in the summer is he the guy
who um has come with some of the
vietnamese yes
yeah okay that's cool that's cool those
are amazing oh my god i love those
hearing from those guys out of this
world
so they're working so they meet they're
so they're working at a cafe in yosemite
dad's checking mom out and um
asked her out and she's like okay
like let's go she's like do you play
tennis he's like
yeah he didn't play tennis at all
she's like okay cool let's go play as
their first date so they went out in the
tennis court
she beat him six love six love for the
non-tennis players that means zero
he got zero points but i think the key
word was actually love
i could see where this is going love and
what
became uh a very healthy competition
he he then later on went and became a
actual tennis pro
um and they've been married now almost
i think 53 years and still play
tennis almost every day together that's
awesome um
but that was how that was how mike and
carol gabbard began
and uh the first i think one of the
yeah i think the first time um he went
to visit my mom in michigan
after they were they were going out for
a little while
um and my mom
i think actually i think they were going
out for a little while and my mom had
decided like she wanted to marry this
guy and
told my grandma and my dad happened to
be in the garage about to walk in the
door and started over here this
conversation inside the house
and um heard my grandmother's response
to my mom
saying carol but he's not even white
how can you marry him and uh
dad was a little taken aback and
turned around and went back and got in
the car and
went went and took a little bit of time
um
but it was just a reflection of the
complete stark differences and
where they were from and you know their
views of
the world and you know obviously they
fell in love with my dad
and uh um
it was uh yeah uh bringing together of
two different people two different
backgrounds and and ultimately you know
my dad took her
uh away from the mainland and and to to
samoa where they both went
as teachers they both got jobs as
teachers there my mom was doing um
she's a speech therapist so helping kids
who had different kind of speech
issues and dad became i think the
assistant dean of the community college
there he was an english major
and so they the three there's five kids
in our family and the three middle
kids uh were all born there and then we
moved to hawaii when i was
two years old so hawaii's been home for
me ever since
did you get to hawaii and i mean you're
what's what's it like when you get there
what like what are your memories of
growing up in hawaii what were your
formative memories
so was one of my earliest memories so so
i'm four of five so my little
sister was his baby of the family and
she was she was born in hawaii and
um she
basically she came a little sooner than
expected and so my dad delivered her at
home
quickly and i watched that happen
that was that was a big strong dose of
reality and
you know i'm i'm three years old at the
time
can you remember it i have i i vaguely
remember remember
pretty much i i don't remember like i
can't visualize it
but i do remember being somewhat
traumatized by it
yeah well the story goes that like my
babysitter who was there also
that that after witnessing that um i
told her like
i never ever want to do that
but um yeah so uh we we moved around
grew up on the island of oahu what was
your parents doing for work there
they were teachers um they were teachers
there
um they had started kind of a small a
small private school
that we went to and then um and then
they ended up
the school had to close down for for one
reason or another um
but then anyway they ended up teaching
us we were homeschooled
and they ended up teaching us and a
bunch of other kind of kids in the
neighborhood
at home and then they they're they're
entrepreneurs at heart they've always
been even
back in samoa they were teaching but
they had uh mike's ten
mike sports shop they had his little
sports shop and so they've always had
some kind of side gig
happening and always different ideas for
new businesses
and and eventually they opened a kind of
family-style deli restaurant healthy
healthy
eating so they they've done a lot of
different things
in their lives and um it's always been
uh
family family affairs everything that's
going on you
did you have involvement were you making
sandwiches down at the deli i'm the one
i get to take credit for coming up with
the name of the restaurant it was called
the natural deli
and we i remember us sitting around the
family living room and having a
brainstorm session
and we're all we are all quite
competitive uh
and the the deal was whoever get whoever
comes up with the name of the restaurant
gets one free dinner at the restaurant
apparently you're competitive but not a
great negotiator exactly completely
i had no idea i felt very victorious in
my my
of my win however had no idea that we
would pretty much be eating there
every day
and so how long were you in this
homeschool before it was cool
scenario i um all the way through high
school
really yeah yep and uh it was so there's
a five-year gap between
me and my closest brother the three boys
are about two years apart and then
the there's there's there's a story that
my dad loves to tell which is that after
the three boys my mom was like
that's it i'm done um she got her tubes
tied she was seriously done it was she
wasn't just saying it
this is in samoa like way back when
where the hospital today is still
probably about
you know 20 years behind modern medicine
so
um so i took my dad a few years but he
finally convinced her
to to uh have more kids
so she went to the hospital in samoa
she's like okay gotta undo what i did
here
and it worked and so my sister and i
came along and and that so there's a
five-year gap between us and
every birthday for me and my sister he's
like girls
you better thank me you wouldn't be here
without me
and your mom your mom too but what were
you thinking of when you were when
you're going to high school what are you
thinking of doing with your life
um i didn't have i didn't have
a specific profession in mind or career
path or anything
i did understand and realize from a
really young age
even before high school that um
i think i think two big two big things
number one was that
i was happiest when i was
um when i was doing things for other
people so you know we go out and we do
like
beach cleanups and and you know growing
up in hawaii's
i love the ocean i literally like i
learned how to swim
at ala moana beach you know in in the in
the shore there and
and um just just loved our home and and
from a really young age had a really
deep appreciation
and a kind of a sense of being a
protector for our home
and so you know we we'd go out and and
um
you know do beach cleanups and do other
things and i just i just felt
happiest when i was doing things for
others when i when i could be of service
and um understood and realized from a
young age that that's what i wanted to
do
and and really in a deeper spiritual way
understanding that
i was happiest when being of service to
god and
what better way to be of service to god
than to
care for and to serve god's children and
and this
this planet so that was something that i
knew in a decision i made
very early on but what exactly that
would look like how you know what path
that would take i had i had no
no idea but i also knew and i i
distinctly remember
i was probably 11 or 12 and i
felt this
reality that
i didn't know how much time i would have
in this life
and that death was something that could
come
at any time and i
knew that i
wanted to and needed to make the most
of my life and the time that i had
and understanding how precious that was
was there anything that triggered that
did you lose a family member
did you see a fish die on the beach or
something like that or was it just
something that came from i mean it came
it came
from um there was no kind of
external trigger um i think it really
came from
spending time in prayer and meditation
frankly
um because i mean this this was
something
this was something that you know god has
been the center of
i mean it's the center of my parents
marriage and it's not not in a sectarian
way at all just understanding hey real
religion is love for god and
however you choose to worship at home or
a church or a temple or
a mosque or whatever however you choose
to
develop that relationship with god that
your happiest
that is where you can find peace and
shelter
and happiness and and um
that that i think is the foundation
that allowed me at a young age to
realize that truth and not in a way that
like oh my god i'm so scared
i'm gonna like i could die tomorrow not
not not
in a fear-filled way at all but
rather just a sense of understanding the
truth
um that is not only
you know we have no control over when
our time will come
and uh therefore
surrender that surrender to that and
surrender
to knowing that hey my my life is
ultimately in god's hands
and also knowing that
the death of this physical body does not
mean the death of
me the soul within the body
and therefore
understanding that being free from the
fear of
death but understanding also
how precious this this life is and
[Music]
wanting to do my best to make sure that
i didn't
waste waste it
well it's amazing you and i can actually
even have a conversation as two human
beings because if you're talking about
when you were 10 or 11 years old
and you're thinking about what you were
thinking about when you were 10 or 11
years old
first of all i did i didn't think i
could be killed
and that lasted until my mid-30s i think
and then on top of that like um you're
talking about serving people and helping
people and i
more than anything just wanted a machine
gun
did you so were you you mentioned that
that religion was part of your life what
what you know what religion did you get
obviously that must have come from home
because you were homeschooled so it was
your parents
what sort of religious view did you
all have what was it it
was it was the i think the deepest
um truest meaning of religion itself
which
is is that real religion is is
love cultivating a loving relation
personal loving relationship with god
and so the backdrop on that which is um
i appreciate so much not
having not not understanding kind of
what is sectarianism
um as as a as a kid growing up at all my
mom
grew up in a methodist family my dad
grew up in a catholic family
um my dad went to seminary for a while
he thought he wanted to become a priest
and and both in their own ways
um ended up coming to a point separately
and then later together
in um wanting more
than they were getting from the
religious or spiritual practice that
they had that they had grown up with
and like for my dad he's told me how um
in the seminary when he went you know
as a kid he had grown up memorizing a
verse i think or
a prayer that said something like in
order to be happy
one must know love and serve
god and so as a kid he's thinking okay
know love and serve god in order to
love like the first step of that
is you have to know god how can i know
god
so that i can love and serve him
and he asked one of the the priests at
the seminary that question like
where can i where and how can i know
more about god and um
the priest kind of patted him on the
head and he said you know this is a
mystery my
my child this is a mystery and so for my
dad who's like well i don't like that
doesn't compute how do you how do you
love someone if you can't know
who they are and so he like even as i
don't know he was a teenager i think at
the time and that that kind of
planted the seed of that hunger for more
knowledge and that more
uh you know having the depth of that
personal
um relationship with god and
and ultimately um they both found
their ways again through different paths
to um
looking at you know eastern spiritual
practices and
meditation and and found um
scriptures and teachings um based in
uh the vedic scriptures which come out
of
india and hinduism but that are also
not sectarian like you don't convert
into
hinduism or you don't convert out of it
they're
timeless kind of universal spiritual
teachings of
bhakti yoga something called bhakti yoga
and karma yoga bhakti yoga being
a spiritual practice in seeking to live
your life in
in loving service to god and karma yoga
if people are familiar with the word
karma
which really means action and karma yoga
meaning
um doing your best to take actions that
have a positive impact to be of service
to others
and so those those are the spiritual
practices that that i
have in my life um
and that i was introduced to from from
a really young age so it's not it
to answer this is a very long answer to
your question but it's not about
like it wasn't like we at you know we
went to bed my mom would say the lord's
prayer and read
stories about you know krishna from the
bhagavad-gita
and you know we'd watch jesus of
nazareth like
1600 times because that was one of the
few movies we were allowed to watch as
kids growing up
and um you know celebrate
celebrate um uh celebrations like john
lost me which is which is the the
celebration of the appearance of krishna
in this world over 5000 years ago and
celebrate christmas and set up the
nativity scene and sing christmas carols
and
there was never ever any
any sense of uh contradiction
or having to choose one or the other you
know we go to mass with my grandmother
when she came to town and go to
and and there was no contradiction
because frankly when you get
right to the heart of it once you get
past all the all of the unfortunate
um like bureaucracy and divisiveness
that that exists too often that create
conflict amongst
people of different spiritual practices
you just get to the heart of it what is
it it is about loving god
and whether you call god krishna or
allah or
jehovah god has many names there's one
god he has many names
and it doesn't matter none of that
none of none of the the superficial
matters if
in your heart you're doing your best to
love god
and to serve him and so that's
that that i'm grateful to have been able
to realize myself
from from a relatively young age
and knew that that is how i wanted to
live my life so how did you
end up with so so you have this
really kind of heavy spiritual
background
what what where were you grounded to
like
interacting with other kids who were
jerks
and you know it seems like you could be
sort of a
a little bit sheltered in this world i
could be totally wrong but it seems like
if that's the way you're raised and all
of a sudden you know you go down to the
market and someone
says you know get out of my way you you
know you little brat or whatever
how do you what was the what was how did
the rest of how did you interact with
the rest of the world when you were in
this stage of yeah you know we weren't
i i we weren't we weren't sheltered or
kind of closed off
we had a lot of you know there's a lot
of kids in the neighborhood and
um we we you know oftentimes like my mom
was the head cook at the restaurant
and so she'd go in at like two in the
morning to start cooking we'd go in with
my my sister and i'd go with my dad a
little later on we do school in the
office with him and then
spend the rest of the day like either
wiping tables or hanging out with
customers and just talking story and
and um like that that was a little bit
of a second home for us
you know did gymnastics did martial arts
did did all the things
and um you know there was no
there was no um
i don't know separation or anything like
that
yeah no so it sounds like there was
balance and oh yeah or you know working
at a restaurant that's what i should
have put that together because when
you're working at a restaurant you got
customers you got people
people that are happy people that are
sad people that are mad people are going
to tell you to you know go screw
yourself and that your sandwich sucked
and people that are like oh this is
wonderful
you get all those people yeah so you
learn a lot about the world
and so that's a good that's a good
balance very much so very much so
so sports you just mentioned kind of
like no big deal martial arts gymnastics
how into you were
how into you were all how into all of
that were you
very much so um i loved
i loved gymnastics until i started to
suck cause i got really
like too big and i think i started to
grow
um and then i i transitioned i was i was
definitely more of
i you know tried ballet as a little girl
too and
me and ballet didn't jive so well
so uh my sister was definitely more of
like
the the the the ballerina type and
i don't know i just it was not not so
much my
my flavor so um i i definitely
gravitated towards martial arts and
earliest did taekwondo and
started learning tai chi and um
chan and filipino stick fighting arnis
and so got got introduced to a lot of
different types of martial arts and
i was that kid that was told like okay
if you want to like toughen yourself up
you need to go across the street to the
park and
kick a tree trunk over and over it's
like
sweet awesome i was the kid that
and maybe echo can relate i'd never
liked wearing shoes
and would purposely like we'd go hiking
up a mountain
and i'd be like shoes shoes are for weak
people
i need to make my feet tough cause i
don't want howly feet
so that was that was kind of me growing
up and
and maybe you know having three older
brothers who who had a lot of fun
making me and my sister do really stupid
uh
tortures a strong word but you know
we'll call them challenges
yeah let's call them challenges
challenges that really had no good
outcome
one way or the other for for us other
than being tough yes
other than being tough uh have you been
to yosemite
i have not i forget which hike it was
but you know my son was the same way
like no shoes ever and we hiked
one of the legit hikes at yosemite just
a day hike but
you know many thousands of feet of
altitude and many miles of walking
and he did it bare feet barefoot and
people were walking by him
and they're just disturbed they're
looking at me like
[Music]
it was literally no factor for him yeah
i mean a zero factor
because the kid would never wear shoes
ever
so that and you know the kid's got tough
feet he can sprint on just
gravel yeah you know are your feet still
tough
probably not as tough just because you
know you like have to wear like a suit
and
heels and all those things for work that
was an adjustment
now your feet are weak i know i have
work to do
where was this by the way what part of
oahu did you grow up with
so my sister was born in wahiawa and um
that's where we lived then but most of
my childhood was
um in kalihi valley and and then later
later was like downtown honolulu
so a little diverse little little slice
of each
each of the different kind of cultures
and communities on oahu
what year did you graduate then from
high school or
graduate from home school that would
have been
like a 97 i think okay
so you get done with high school then
what what are you doing
um so i had started an environmental
knowledge because
spirituality doesn't pay the rent
unfortunately so yeah did you work that
out i had um
so i had started uh co-founded
environmental nonprofit uh called
healthy hawaii coalition
um maybe i was 16 or 17 and i was
thinking about
i figured out like okay you know we're
going and doing beach cleanups on the
weekends and every weekend we come back
and there's more trash
on the beach like how do we start to try
to solve
a deeper problem and and came up with an
idea of
of going and talking elementary school
kids about like
hey guys here's why you shouldn't like
throw your soda can in your chip
bag on the beach because
this is our home this is our playground
and here's what happens when you
when you do that and and i came up with
like um
like a fun little skit called the
adventures of water woman
and a friend of mine who's an artist
came up with like a workbook and a
coloring book for
for kids and i thought elementary
because you know obviously kids are
starting to figure things out and um
yeah so we we had this this two-day
program one day was the skit
and the workbook and then the next day
we actually took kids out to to like a
field trip and like testing water and
understanding like okay here's like
clean water versus dirty water and
why and how it gets contaminated but in
a very simple practical way that they
could
really relate to uh in their lives and
so i was the original water woman
i had like the blue board shorts and the
cape with the big water drop on the back
and it was so much pictures there
they exist there may even be a video
somewhere i don't know but
so it was water woman and her nemesis
was oily al
and uh the skit was really a day in the
life of oily al
and you know he'd be out there like you
know throwing his trash out on the
street or
changing the oil in his car and then
dumping the dirty oil down a storm drain
you know dumping a bunch of pesticides
in his garden and every step of the way
um you know water woman comes in just in
the nick of time and saves the day and
tells oily owl like
if you dump your dirty car oil down the
storm drain it's going to kill all the
fish
in the water and you know when telling
the kids when you go surfing the water's
going to be really gross and it was just
the coolest
thing to like see all these kids sitting
cross-legged on the ground
like you know first second third graders
and
seeing kind of like the light bulb go
off in their eyes
because these were examples that they
could understand
and and relate to and that was my hope
in doing this was that
you know it would at least plant a seed
for them to
understand and appreciate there are
consequences to your actions
and um we care very much about
our home and so stop and think for a
minute before you do something or if you
see
uncle or auntie like auntie don't throw
your trash out the car window
and and be able to start to make more of
a
you know behavioral kind of change and
impact
um to protect our home
did you get these you know what now was
your dad your dad was in politics
at some level in hawaii wasn't he he um
he and i might the first person our
family who ran actually ran for office
was my mom she ran for board of
education
um i think it was in it was in 2000
oh okay so so the water woman
that was predated that yeah
that's just but that's what inspired me
eventually like it got to a point where
and and and healthy hawaii coalition
still exists today there are other water
women's have
have come after me um
but she's still out there but it got to
a point where i
i so i started going to community
college and
with the aim of working in the tv and
film industry
leeward community college and started
the tv and film
production course out there and then was
going to transfer to a mainland school
to be able to continue continue that
kind of education
um but a couple of things happen
uh my financial aid package fell through
and i couldn't afford it
to come to the mainland and so and then
the other thing was just
um there there was a an open
uh seat in the state legislature where i
lived
and i i you know i i started to think
about okay
um i have an opportunity here to
stand on the outside and there were
other things you know we they wanted to
build a
huge landfill over one of our biggest
water aquifers in hawaii all of our
water comes from groundwater so
you know i and a whole bunch of other
people we went out and got petitions and
we organized and
ultimately thankfully were able to get
that that project cancelled
but it it got as far as it did because
of a politician
who is kind of in the pocket of the
landfill company
and so i started to think you know i can
i can stand on the outside
and hold a sign or circulate a petition
or i can
try to put myself in a position of
influence
and decision making to um directly
impact
a lot of these environmental issues that
i really cared a lot about and that's
what led me to
uh run for state house in 2002
uh my how old were you i was 21. and my
dad that was the first
that my dad ran for city council that
same year so it was kind of it was kind
of
fun for us to share he ran for city
council out in waianae
and i was running for state house in ewa
beach and so our districts
like they didn't overlap really but they
were adjacent to each other but
every morning it was like okay my mom
would pack a lunch
and um uh send him out and i went out we
were sign waving every day and knocking
on doors every day for
for months but that was that was both of
our introduction into running for office
at the same time and it was for me it
was a totally
it was a totally foreign experience
because i had no you know formal
education in it i was not a part of a
debate
team had not been trained to public
speak in any way at all
and on top of all of that total 100
introvert like you know i had my circle
of friends growing up
but i was i was so shy
and i was fine with it because i just
hung out with who i wanted to hang out
with but anybody outside of that
i would not um
i wouldn't talk to people i'd make my
sister go out and talk to people
and i'd read books and do my martial
arts and
yoga and just do do my thing and so to
then put choose to put myself in a
position
where i'd have to learn how to give
speeches i'd have to figure out how to
pick up the phone and call total
strangers which was
anxiety-inducing in and of itself but
not only do that but ask them like hey
would you like to donate to my campaign
for state house to then go like i
never forget the first day i went to go
knock on doors like i knew enough about
i'd done enough research to know okay if
i'm gonna run for this seat i'm gonna
run to win
and in order to do that i have to
convince this
many people to vote for me in order to
win this race
so i had i had the math figured out and
i had the voting list
people's addresses and names and um
literally got on the computer made like
this black and white kind of janky
brochure
saying this is who i am and so i had you
know
copies of that that i went and made at
the coffee shop and
and i sat in my car it's like a aqua
colored
geo metro two-door geo metro
um on old ewa beach road in
in waipahu and um
it took me about 30 minutes in the car
to summon up the courage to go knock on
that first door
and i was terrified absolutely terrified
just thinking of
every scenario that could possibly go
wrong
but also like what are the first words
that need to come out of my mouth
and then what if they ask me this
question what if i don't know the answer
just all of these different things
and and you know like one knocked on the
first door and like this wonderful old
filipino lady answered the door and
she's like hey
how are you she's wonderfully kind and
offered me a glass of water and like the
whole thing's like oh my god
okay then went through the whole
scenario all over again for the next
door
a whole scenario like every single door
was
was a major obstacle uh for me and and
ultimately like
why put myself through this and and how
did i get through it it really just
it that groundedness and and
the ability to step way outside of
anything i was comfortable with came
from
um that that desire to serve and knowing
that ultimately keeping reminding myself
ultimately like why do you care so much
about yourself this is not about you
if you wanted to do something for
yourself you would certainly not be
doing this you'd be out surfing right
now
and um and that was that was my
introduction
into uh into elected
politics so you won did your dad win i
won
and he won yep and my mom my mom
was serving she served one four-year
term in the board of education so
for two years from 2002 to four
um the three of us were all like in
serving in different buildings all in
the same kind of you know
quarter quarter mile quarter square mile
area
in honolulu it was it was fun and and
obviously you liked it at some level you
liked the impact that you were able to
have
because you carried on with this sort of
yeah
it is life i never once
thought you know when i won that
election it was a five-way
democratic primary first that i had to
get through and then a general election
that i got through um
i i yes i liked the impact but i
never once thought that i want to have a
career
quote-unquote career in politics i was
absolutely not attached to that i
thought okay hey this is something i can
do
now and i'll make the most of it and
then you know we'll see
we'll see where it goes and i ended up
serving
just one term there because of um
iraq so when did you
when did september 11th happen or what
so i was where were you at yeah so i was
i was um just starting my my campaign
uh to run for the state house when that
happened
and at what point did you decide you
wanted to enlist in the
the national guard in hawaii
i i
knew in some way um when
9 11 happened and obviously we're in
hawaii you know we're
six hours behind new york on that day
so we woke up to
turning on the news and it had already
happened
um and you know i think like
like everybody in our country it was it
um
it deep it's it deeply impacted me in a
way that i
felt almost right away that i wanted to
do something to to
to go after and defeat the terrorists
that attacked us
then um i just didn't quite know exactly
how to do that because i was i had
already made a decision to pursue this
particular path of
being able to serve hawaii
and um so eventually
eventually i felt that i
had learned about the national guard and
what it's about and you know serve your
state
in its time of need but also be ready to
stand up and serve your country and
and uh decided to enlist in
early 2003 because i felt that would be
a way that i could
accomplish both objectives essentially
did you have familiarization with the
military because of your grandfather
that had spent his
whole career in the army and in the air
force or were you
really just just through stories um he
passed away while i was still
relatively young and because they he and
my grandmother lived in samoa we didn't
get a ton of time together
um my dad had had and his high school
best friend
had tried to enlist to serve in vietnam
they had both gone to i guess it would
have been
meps or some sort of version of it and
they both walked in together and went
into different rooms
to go through all the medical exams and
stuff he wanted to be a medic
and when they came out my dad had been
rejected for medical reasons
it may have been flat feet or something
like that and he was
he was totally heartbroken but his best
friend came out and
was enlisted and so ended up going and
serving
in vietnam but it was something that my
dad always
wished that he had um been able to do
just to to be able to serve and so
um that was prob that was pretty much
the most of
my personal no no one else in my family
my some of my uncles had served but
again we're in hawaii so like we don't
you know they don't get to see them or
hang out with them that much so
so you show up to boot do you go to boot
camp yeah camp
i had i was in the state legislature at
the time and so i had to
i you know took the asvab and everything
the recruiter is like
yeah you can you can have whatever job
you want just tell me what you want to
do
and literally made the decision i was
like
look my session is done on this date and
then i gotta be back by this date
so find me a basic training and an ait
that can fit within these like this five
month period i gotta knock it all out
at once and so i ended up uh
in a um like medical
uh operations or something like that
because the ait was only seven weeks
long
i advise like i want to do like uh
combat journalism or something like that
but you got to go to school for six
months or whatever but
so i shipped out right after the
legislative session was done i enlisted
on the uh actually on
the floor of the state house and um went
to fort jackson
the summer of 2003
um managed to um
not get noticed by the drill sergeants
for my political job until like
week seven of nine which i was
pretty happy about and only got found
out because um
[Music]
uh me and my my assigned battle buddy
we were pulling duty at like the
battalion headquarters one afternoon
uh like watching the door whatever it
was and
the battalion star major walked in and
did what sergeant majors do uh like
hey privates how are you and where do
you come from and
what'd you do before you joined the army
and you know that whole conversation
and so he talked to my battle buddy
first and she told him
i think she was from the midwest and
she's like yeah so you know i was
working at mcdonald's and
decided to join the military and this is
what i want to do and
it's like oh you know that's great it's
great and what about you
it's like oh yeah i'm from hawaii and
um i'm a state representative there and
you know this is what i want to do and
and he just looked at me he's like wait
you said what
you do what he's like how come i don't
know about this
he asked me that how come i don't know
about this like
i don't i don't know uh i you know the
in processing paperwork that says
what is your civilian occupation i i
wrote it down and turned it in but you
know
who's your drill sergeant
going from hawaii going from like the
kind of
cruising mode of hawaii yeah which i
know it sounds like there's
there's a little bit of well there's
there's also like this whole competitive
thing with your family and
you're obviously we're driven because
you're out creating these things and
running for office and all this
but i mean all of a sudden you're in
boot camp
was it a shock of course yeah yeah
i mean it's i'd be worried if if it
wasn't a shock
um but i i'm really you know i'm happy
that i went in with the perspective
of at least just understanding that
whatever the madness is there's a
purpose to it
and don't get i i just i've never i've
always been
a pretty chill person and i don't get
freaked out by that much
and um yeah so
yeah i i actually in a very weird and
twisted way really loved it
it was it was the the camaraderie and
the kind of bond that that
is built in a very short period of time
with a whole bunch of strangers from all
over the country
knowing that and appreciating that like
all of us are there for the same reason
all of us are there for the same purpose
whatever the motivating decision was to
enlist really
didn't matter that um
you know we all were the same uniform
and all on the same team was
it was i loved it how long after you got
back from boot camp and ait was it that
you went on your first deployment
came back home at the end of 2003 from
training
and then the 29th brigade combat team
from the hawaii national guard was
activated
i want to say um the notification came
out in the summer of 2004.
i was campaigning for my re-election at
that point in time
and um remember
going in and and uh taking a break
from knocking on doors knocking on doors
again
and uh i got an email at home checked my
email at home and
and uh got the notification of the
deployment
but i was not on the i was not on the
deployment roster
because they they already had somebody
who filled
you know that job in the medical in the
field medical company
and so i immediately called my commander
and just said hey
like what's what's the deal here i don't
see my name on the roster
and he said tulsi congratulations like
you get to stay home you don't have to
go and
um that bothered me a lot
and i i just said no um i
i just you know i i knew that there was
no way i could stay back
and that to
you know sit in my office in the state
capitol and watch everybody leave was
not an option
for me and so i i continued the
conversation with my
my commander and i just said sir um i'm
going
tell me what job i need to get trained
in that you need filled so that i can go
and that's that's that's what happened
so i i kind of
i publicly withdrew from my reelection
campaign it was too late to take my name
off the ballot but
told everybody like i'm not i'm not
running for reelection
um volunteered uh to fill this position
and
we left restarted our active duty train
up
uh i think it was in august of of that
year of 2004 and then we were in country
in early january 2005.
what job did you get trained for what
job what bill it did you
it was medical logistics um so supply
um which and you're a specialist at this
point yeah i was an e4
that's kind of a fresh e4
and as as you know like okay i felt i
filled the position but once we actually
got there
i ended up becoming i ended up filling
a position that was previously held by
an e7
as the brigade surgeon operations
person and so kind of was working you
know like line of duty paperwork
and injuries and um
tracking supplies for all of our medics
and docs and pas who were
uh attached to all of like the infantry
units and
and and also uh every day just tracking
um going through going through the the
report every day for
our brigade commander of looking
name by name down this list of
casualties that had occurred in the
previous 24 hours
to see if there was anyone there from
our
nearly 3 000 person brigade and
make sure that they were getting taken
care of whether
in country to stay in country or getting
them evacuated and
staying with them and tracking their
care every step of the way until
eventually
they made their way home where were you
actually stationed in iraq
we were in uh balad in lsa anaconda
most of us were there that was kind of
the base and then we had units in camp
victory in baghdad
and then a couple other kind of smaller
fobs out
in different areas and so i moved around
i moved around a little bit kind of
going out and visiting some of our units
and
checking in on them um where they you
know
where they were but that was that was
primarily where i spent most of the time
and how did you what was that deployment
like from
you know your perspective now looking
back
what kind of lessons did you bring back
what did you learn
from that from that deployment to iraq
a lot yeah i i came back
and my family told me this after i don't
think i fully realized how much
i had changed but it was something that
they
immediately noticed in um
in in coming back just
more sober and
more focused uh and that that really
came from
you know i talked a little bit about how
realizing from a young age like death
can come at any moment well that's
that's a philosophical realization
and being there that became
very real very quickly
um and you know there there was
have you been there did you ever pass
through there when i went to balad i'd
be there for like
20 minutes and go to a meeting and leave
so i
barely remember anything about did you
come in like
vehicle or bird yeah so there was there
was
within the first couple of days of of us
arriving there it's a big
camp massive and so you know i kind of
was going out and like okay orienting
myself where's everything at
and i noticed right away at at the north
gate of that camp
at least at that time i don't know if
it's still there but there was a big
there's a big huge sign that someone had
put up
on you know that you would see every
time you leave camp out through the
north gate which is where most of our
patrols um
use that gate that the sign read is
today the day
and i just remember being stopped in my
tracks and just
taking a minute to to to take that in
and the meaning of it
so that none of us would ever forget
that today could be the day
and um that that was
the welcome message and
it really
it it hit home so much
um in in that daily task that i had of
of actually seeing names of people who i
never knew
people in different parts of who were
serving different parts of the country
but also people who i did know
whose names would pop up on that list
every single day that i went through
and recognizing again how precious life
is
and any any any day any moment
um you know that that could be your last
and then of course
we we had unfortunately you know we lost
we lost a lot of people during that
deployment and
um to me it it really
it changed everything for me because
ultimately
coming home i knew there was absolutely
no way
that i could just go back to the life
that i had left
behind as though i didn't just
experience like the people like oh
you're going to go back and run for your
seat in the state legislature you're
going to pick this up and
kind of like hit the play button on my
life that had been paused and
it was impossible i didn't even think
about it
because i knew that somehow this
experience that i had had i wanted
i wanted to do something um positive
with it uh in in being able to impact
the kinds of
decisions that
took us all to that war in the first
place
so then so then what was the next move
when you get home it's two is it now two
thousand
2000 yeah so we were in country for a
year
and uh then you know had the
demobilization when we came back
and uh so it was 2006 and i was trying
to figure out okay what what am i going
to do there was no obvious answer
to the question that i was asking which
was how can i you know
how can i take this and turn it into
something positive
ultimately i ended up volunteering our
one of our us senators from hawaii at
that time um
senator akaka was being challenged in a
primary election
which kind of unheard of um
you know the the power of incumbency is
is very real
plus he's like the kindest most aloha
guy you will ever ever meet in your
entire life
no one has a bad thing to say about him
but he got this challenge that came out
of nowhere and
i didn't know him at all personally i
had no personal relationship whatsoever
the guy challenging him um
i did have some some interaction with
um that was not positive and so i was i
was like okay
i'm gonna go volunteer full-time for
senator akaka
make sure that that um that he wins his
re-election
uh and he did and he i don't know if he
was already or i think he was
after the re-election he became the
chairman of the u.s senate
committee for veterans affairs and so
after volunteering on the campaign as
chief of staff said hey do you want to
come and work in washington
and as a legislative aide and help him
with that work on the committee and
and you know environment and energy
natural resource few other areas and
so that's what i did um i ended up going
and working with him
in washington for a couple years
went through ocs while i was there and
how did you get an ocs billet did you
graduate college somewhere along the way
good question
i forgot about that part i was
working i i was i was um
while in iraq working on my degree going
on the education center tent and you
know like okay sometimes you got mortars
coming in and
the alarm sounds you got to go in the
bunker and come back out and
say i was i was continuing my education
while i was there
and i had gotten just enough credits you
needed 60 credits to go to ocs
and i had just enough credits to go
and i was still working on my degree
when i was in dc and i was you know
working there and so i was kind of
working full-time and doing school at
night
um but yeah slid in slid in uh
and then got i think you needed 90
credits to get your commission
or something like that you still had to
keep squeaking them out so
yeah so i just uh i barely squeaked by
and then um so you go to ocs is it
anything anything shocking about ocs
anything that was
i loved i i knew obviously ocs is to
train leaders but i didn't
know going in um the depth of that and
that was why
that was why i wanted to go through ocs
when i graduated from basic training i
was like i want to be the sergeant major
of the army one day
all about it and then you know i got a
deployment under my belt and got to
witness
some some examples of of great
leadership also some examples of leaders
that were lacking in a lot of areas and
and
especially in a deployed setting in a
dangerous way
and um that was that that made a major
impact for me coming back
to say okay you know i same thing like
i can complain about having shitty
leaders or i can actually go and try to
be
be a good leader of soldiers and and i
love
and i tell kids who come and ask me like
hey i think i want to join the military
become an officer
very biased yes you can go do the west
point thing and that's great
i highly highly highly recommend ocs
because it is
it is intense it is relatively short
and it is just like it is it is the
essentials
of providing it provides you with the
essential tools
to to begin your leadership uh path
and i just i loved it so much that i
ended up going back
as a tax officer after i had gotten a
deployment as a platoon leader under my
belt
and then i loved it even more
how long is this how long is army rcs
so there's the active duty army ocs at
fort benning which is i think
three maybe between three and four
months
i went through an accelerated national
guard ocs in alabama
at fort mcclellan that uses the same
program of instruction as the as the
fort benning program but just condenses
it down to i think it was
maybe 10 weeks
and like you know the difference is like
they they get weekends off at fort
benning like they get to use computers
and phones and
like that and we got none of that it was
it was seven days a week you know
four a.m to midnight um all up orders
like no access to technology whatsoever
so everything you were doing
it was like you're writing it you're
writing your your
six page op order yourself and um
you know it sucked as you're going
through it of course but
you know i i'm old enough now i'm
approaching 18 years now
in in the army reserves and uh so i'm
like one of those old people who's like
man you guys got it so good now
back in the day
back in the day um
you uh so then you go on another
deployment and this time you go
to kuwait yeah you're in kuwait that
time yeah yeah we were
um it was a different it was a different
mission for the brigade and kind of each
of the battalions were tasked out in a
lot of different areas
a lot of our our infantry battalions or
cav battalions were doing convoy
security
from within kuwait in and out of iraq um
my platoon was attached to a field
artillery battalion
and we were we i i'm so grateful for
this but we were
we were physically located very very far
away from the flagpole
um and then the big bases that exist in
kuwait so we were
within an active kuwaiti naval base
and right on the water which you know
that's my gig i gotta be close to the
water if i can
um but our our main mission um
the artillery battalion had kind of a
force protection mission
but my platoon uh we had had two things
one was
kind of security um
like like high level security if we had
vips coming into kuwait or and we worked
with the embassy a lot we did a lot of
stuff in and around the embassy
so like psd like personal security um
you know we did security for a lot of
the the ammunition movements from
the ports to where they had to go
uh and then also um we did i had a
training mission which was the
which was the the fun one for me it was
being able to go and train the the
kuwaiti
army on you know marksmanship
um basic you know how to clear a
building uh
what do you do if you're dealing with uh
like a civil disturbance or a riot
right tactical tulsa
teaching the wrong appearances hell yeah
it was it was it was interesting for me
though
because um you know i platoon leader for
a military police platoon
in kuwait where
i didn't realize until we got there they
don't allow women on their bases at
all it doesn't matter if you're the
general's wife
or you're a janitor there are no women
what if you're tulsi gabbard
tulsi gabbard showed up
and i really didn't know when we rolled
up like that first day to go in and meet
the unit and meet the unit commander
obviously i'm in uniform and my hair is
up i got you know
a big ball of hair on the back of my
head and i didn't know what they were
going to do
at the gate did you have other females
in your platoon i had
i had um two two females in my platoon
there were um one was an e3 and one was
an e4
the rest were you know these are guys
who are working state
local or federal law enforcement mostly
at home in their civilian jobs and
just about all of them had uh at least
one or two deployments under their belt
and so they're they're seasoned
experienced guys
um but yeah so i showed up i showed up
on day one and you know kind of showed
my id card at the gate and the gate
guard was
didn't really know what to do but
he saw you know he saw the american flag
and he was like
well okay go ahead and and so
uh my i was my partner in this was a
master sergeant at e8
and um super super cool easy going
guy and and so we went and we started to
uh we got introduced to the the guys
that we'd be training
we ended up doing a number of iterations
of different groups of guys but
um you know kind of went down the line
shaking hands
and saying hello and uh
there was probably half of the kuwaiti
guys who
i was invisible there certainly was no
shaking of hands certainly no eye
contact or even acknowledgement
that i was standing there and you know
okay got it challenge
how do you go from like i don't exist in
your universe
to actually being able to help provide
you with some
instruction and and develop the rapport
necessary to be able to do that
and um you know so i
i kind of drawing from maybe the aloha
in hawaii of just recognizing hey
you know we're we're different people
different backgrounds different language
different culture different everything
but
i respect like i respect you
and um i'm going to treat you with that
aloha
that respect and um
gradually i started to see the ice kind
of started to thaw
and ultimately you know when we're out
on the range and i'm walking up and i'm
telling them like hey
like okay here's this like basic safety
things and
and then like okay i'm gonna show you
how to do it and then
you know um gradually it got to the
point i knew i knew i had made progress
we sat down for lunch and they started
to share their lunch with me
is all like food food is food is the
ultimate you know bridge builder and
i knew once you were like hey like yeah
here try my food like oh yeah oh
awesome like cool yeah that's really
good and it got to the point where um on
on their graduation day of that first
group their commander
had everybody in the room everybody
seated their getting there getting all
the graduation certificates and
everything and
their commander asked me to come forward
and presented me with this
uh plaque of appreciation and thanks
and uh some of there were some american
civilians who were also
working that um that mission and and
they had been there longer than we had
and they said tell us afterwards they're
like tulsi i hope you understand what a
big deal that was
for this kuwaiti military officer
um you know the traditional bearded
muslim
man to recognize the accomplishments
of a woman and i i was
very grateful to have been able to
experience experience that in
recognizing the bigger significance
that you know not so much about like
well this is about women's rights or
empowerment but
more so about how to overcome seemingly
impossible barriers to get to a place
where you
have mutual professional respect
and understanding uh and and
the power of that alone and there are
obvious parallels that we could point to
in today's world here
in america but yeah yeah i know it's
that's a that's an awesome story and
lately i've been talking a lot about the
fact that if you want respect you got to
give respect if you want people to
listen to you you got to listen to them
if you want to have influence over
people you've got to allow them to
influence you
and if you want to build trust with
people you got to trust them yes
and i it's interesting um you know you
kind of captured
well at least for sure the respect part
is aloha right
it's the aloha spirit of hey you know
what you're a little bit different than
me but it's all good we'll figure it out
and that way of building relationships
is so much better than
you saying hey look i might be a woman
you might not think i'm here but i am a
second lieutenant in the united states
army and you will like okay good luck
with that
you never would have made any progress
at all none
and and so taking a little
a little bit of aloha apparently with a
little lunch as well goes a long way
over time yeah
and and people want to be
confrontational because it seems
like well it's the least offensive thing
to your ego right
when when someone looks at you or
doesn't look at you treats you like
you're not there
that's that can be a blow to your ego
that your ego can't
can't repress it it just has to come out
your ego has to say
you will look at me damn it you know i
am tulsi
listen to me you have to listen and all
those things even though it
seems like it would be you know this
direct
i just need to be direct with them and
tell them that i and it's like okay
i'm telling you that that attitude
doesn't work and look we're talking
about a pretty
serious cultural divide yeah but it
happens with everything
it happens if you and i are trying to
figure out how to execute a mission and
you think we should do it one way and i
think we should do it a different way
and i tell you well tulsi that's because
you don't you haven't done this kind of
operation before or because you you
haven't been in as long as me or because
you don't you you went to ocs and i went
to west point so therefore i know but
all those things are wrong all those
things are going to make it harder for
us to come to a
good an actual good the best possible
decision which is what we want
so putting your ego in check add a
little aloha to that
and and we can actually make some
progress and unfortunately you know it's
kind of like what i started off talking
about you know if you have an idea about
something i have an idea about something
and my my default mode
is to say you're freaking wrong
how are we going to have how are we
going to talk about it how are we going
to actually figure out
what to do no you stay on your side and
i'll stay on my side and we won't do
anything
which is a freaking nightmare yeah and
that's where
that's where i see um the parallel in
that experience with
the aloha that that i strived to bring
every day to my work in washington is
you start with
you know finding that common ground even
with such incredible stark differences
that that are real you start with okay
what what is
what is the common ground that we can
stand on comfortably together
coupled with what is our shared
objective what is the thing that we are
trying to accomplish and recognizing
that
whatever your personal feelings may be
however strong they
may be what your views are ultimately
if you can find some commonality in both
those places
then you recognize that it's not about
you
it's about this shared goal
and purpose that you have and then like
you'll find a way
you'll figure it out again this is
another thing i've been talking a lot
about lately is
if you and i can get aligned we we can
come to a solution
but we sometimes have to go pretty high
up the ladder of alignment to get to a
point where it actually meets so
we have a mission and you want to attack
the target from the left and i want to
attack the target from the right
well that's that's okay as long as we
both know that we want to secure that
target that's what we want to do
and then all one of us has to do is put
our ego in check for
15 seconds and say you know what kelsey
attacking from the right sounds good
let's do it your way right
because i i just want to get to i just
want to get the target secured that's
what i want to do
that's that's okay where we also get
into a problem is agendas now you have
an agenda where you want your platoon to
do it and i want my platoon to do it
so then we have to rise above those
agendas
now it's possible that our agendas that
your agenda's still aligned with the
goal you want to get the target secured
great you want your platoon to do it you
know what if i can put my ego in check
for
15 seconds and say you know what sounds
good tulsi once you take your your
platoon can take lead and i'll support
you right
sounds good all i want to do is get the
mission done
exactly and people run around in circles
and attack each other
and worst part they never make progress
they never make it to the target because
they can't even
they can't even come to any kind of
agreement yeah
that that's that that sounds exactly
like one of the first things i was
introduced to as a new member of
congress
where i the message was delivered very
clearly from
the leadership um within the within the
democratic party and and some of my
republicans went through some of the
same stuff on their side so this isn't
about one party or another but
the message being like hey look this is
about winning
the election and if we're in power it's
about keeping power if
if we are not in power it's about how
how do we get it back
and so if there's a bill for example
that deals with whatever let's say it
deals with transportation
something about as universally agreed
upon as you can get
like we need to move from a to b all of
us do
so there's a bill on transportation
infrastructure
and it's introduced by a republican
you don't support that bill you you
should support
one that could be virtually identical as
long as there's a democrat name
at the top that's leading that effort
because that will allow
the democrat person and the democratic
party that to then take
credit for it which will then be put on
a brochure or a tv ad that you can use
in the next campaign which will get us
closer to
getting power or or uh maintaining
power and this is where we want run into
problems
in the world yeah is when ultimately
we're not aligned that's where the
actual problem comes in
is if you where you want to go the
target that you want to hit
is not the same as the target that i
want to hit and then we can't
we can't overcome these problems because
we are not going to the same place they
don't
they don't they're not the same place so
how are we going to go we can't be
two places at once we either go to your
place or my place and that's where we
run into a problem when people
are saying well the main point of us
doing this
is to get power not to help american
people not to move
transportation in a good direction but
just so we get reelected
and if that's what the goal is we can't
get aligned and it's a problem
and that is exactly where the lack of
alignment exists because you have
a political infrastructure where both
political parties are
ultimately and this is not every single
person but if you look at the goals of
the leadership of both parties
it is about power so right you know i i
served in congress for eight years
um for the first uh like half of my time
there republicans were in charge
democrats were in the minority
and then democrats won and took over the
house democrats are in charge
republicans and minority and you just
see it play out
where whoever's in power is trying to
keep power whoever is not is trying to
is trying to take it and there's no
alignment because they're looking out
for their own
interests for the parties and they are
not
ultimately making decisions about what
legislation comes to the house floor
or what issues are being tackled based
on what's in the best interest of the
country
which is where that alignment must be
and and it's how our system of
governance
was set up that not that you have
everybody as part of one party or
marching in lockstep or having all of
the same views
but instead that you bring the
diversity of different views experiences
and backgrounds and ideas by having in
the house of representatives 435 people
from all across the country all elected
by constituents in their districts
who can then bring their ideas where you
have debate and conversation you have
bills that that
theoretically go through committee where
you can offer amendments and try to
strengthen
whatever the proposal might be or kill
it if it's a bad idea
and then you've got to vote on the floor
like this is civics 101 that we learn
about in school
it does not exist in reality though
today
because instead of figuring out hey how
do we work out our differences and come
to that same goal of like how do we fix
all of the potholes in our roads in
hawaii and all over the country
okay we need to invest in some
infrastructure how do we do that how
much money how is this best going to be
executed
instead and we saw this play out over
you know i
remember when trump first got elected i
reporters asked me what
what do you think tulsi is the one thing
like what's the low-hanging fruit
where there where bipartisan um
agreement and work is possible i and
most other people said
infrastructure every community needs it
every um this is a domestic job creator
that actually solves real problems that
need to be solved
it never happened there was no
infrastructure bill that even
really came before congress for any
serious consideration
and why is that like the most
low-hanging fruit that everybody agrees
on that objective
didn't happen because of partisan
differences and an
unwillingness to say okay yeah democrats
had a certain idea and a certain dollar
amount republicans had a different idea
and a different dollar amount
but there was never any real good faith
serious effort to say okay where can we
meet
in the middle what am i willing to give
up what are you willing to give up
so that we can actually start to deliver
on
fulfilling the needs the very real needs
that exist
within our communities so i know you
said not everyone
is so entrenched but what percentage of
people are entrenched
on the left and the right i would say
most i would say most and and not
because they're
bad people necessarily but
if you look at the system that exists
the power that the political parties
have
is massive and
uh unfortunately there are too
few people who go to washington
willing to uh buck
that power and deal with the
consequences of that and the
consequences being hey
if you don't if you don't toe the party
line then
if you've got a tough challenge in your
re-election campaign we're not going to
help fund
tv ads for you for example or we're not
going to deploy resources to support you
or
we'll pull you off the committee that
that you're on that you you really like
or maybe we're not going to consider
your bill on
we won't allow your bill to come to the
floor for a vote and sometimes these are
very direct statements that are made and
sometimes they're they're
signals that are sent in an indirect way
and um so the result of having too few
people who are willing to kind of stand
up and
and make decisions based on
purely based on on merit versus the
political pressures
is you end up having a lot of people who
either enjoy and get right into
playing the political games um
and are all about it and then you have
other people who
maybe unwillingly or or even as they are
disheartened but feel like they have no
other option than to
play the game and so it you know
uh and and frankly it's because they see
they see people like me uh you know
president obama was present during you
know
i came i was sworn into congress in 2013
so his first four years and then i had
president trump as president for the
last four years that i was in congress
and in both cases
you know if there was an issue that i
agreed on whether it's obama or trump
i spoke out and said it if there's an
issue i disagreed on obama or trump i
spoke out
and said it which is which is is is kind
of
heresy in washington because the
expectation is
even if it's the same exact scenario the
same exact situation if it's your person
in the white house
and you don't like it you don't say
anything but if it's the other
party then i mean the world is gonna end
look at this terrible thing
and it's such a blatant double standard
and so hypocritical
i think this is one of the reason why
voters are just like come on like
we can see what you're doing so
ridiculous
exactly but you know they exist within
this
bubble where the the it's i mean it is
it's i've talked about this before
it's kind of like high school there is a
popularity contest and
it's both people it it's this ecosystem
where people really care a whole lot
about
what parties they're invited to or who
answers
answers their phone calls um
i'm just going to point this out because
i've heard you talk about this before
you're not saying like
oh it's like high school where people
care about what parties
they're invited to you're saying people
actually are thinking well tulsi didn't
invite me to that party so
we're gonna step on her bill that she
put forth i'll give you an example very
it is it is literal it's not like you
know it's not an analogy
it's it's literal there there was you
know in the in the pre-coveted world and
maybe even in the pre-trump world
um the white house correspondents dinner
is like the big event of the year
and it is hosted by the media
for the media and you only get invited
as a politician if someone in the media
invites you to go
as as your guest it's kind of like
washington
dc's um oscars kind of
gala type situation so you know it's all
of the fancies
everything and hollywood celebrities fly
in for it
and it's it's like a it's a really big
thing and
um i i remember you know i
i happened to get an invitation to go
the first year i was there without
knowing anything about what it was
and i was talking to some of my
colleagues they're like tulsi
you got an in like i've like this guy my
friend he's like i've been here seven
years and i've never been invited to
that
like hook a brother up kind of thing and
it was so
i mean it was so surreal to me
especially because having gone from that
where i was invited to go to that or
other things you know like the first few
years i was there and then um
you know uh i stopped getting those
invitations
because like hold on a second she's
actually like
challenging whatever the narrative is or
challenging
decisions made within her own party or
saying or doing things that didn't fall
within the mainstream of popularity in
washington dc
and uh so i've i've experienced the arc
of
like okay you're cool you seem kind of
cool and like you know you're a surfer
you're a veteran you're this you're that
and then all of a sudden like oh wait
hold on
you actually have something to say
that's not just whatever literally the
email talking points are of the day
then you know it turns into something
else
let's uh let's let's rewind it a little
bit to
when you actually ran so you get home
from
in in what 2009 you get home in 2009
um i came back from my second deployment
in 2009
and kind of faced a similar um
pivotal decision point on on what to do
next
and just like the first deployment i
came back with this same kind of sense
of purpose and mission of wanting to
find a way to be in a position where i
could um
i could help influence decisions or make
decisions about
our country's foreign policy and about
our military and
um but didn't know exactly
what or how i would do that i didn't
there was no obvious choice
at that time i had applied for something
called the white house fellows
program uh which i thought would have
been a great opportunity
where basically it's it's a highly
competitive you heard of it before
yeah so it's this highly competitive
program that
ultimately if selected you serve for a
year as
a senior special assistant to a cabinet
member
or to the president or the vice
president um so you kind of you know
jumping your way up to directly being
able to help influence and impact
issues so i had applied for that
got through to the regional finals and
then got through
to the final final interviews which was
i think three days of um
assessment essentially which consisted
of
you know we're told okay as soon as
literally as soon as you arrive there
you're being assessed
by the judges i think there were 12
judges and ultimately they would
choose probably 12 people out of maybe i
think maybe they're 20 of us there
and so whether it was the the welcoming
reception
uh or these actual boards
essentially that you would go
individually and sit before there's you
know i think four different
um boards of three judges
and you know do a q a kind of thing and
and then there was something
that um they gave us an exercise
where all of us who were there we had to
pull names or positions out of a hat
and so i think the position i got was
white house chief of staff
someone else was the president someone
else was the vice president and then
they say okay here's the scenario
i don't remember exactly like country x
has just launched an attack on us
and um you have
you you've convened a meeting in the
situation room
uh execute like you've got 15 minutes to
prepare
and then you go and execute and so role
playing
scenario kind of war gaming thing and um
and the judges are just standing there
watching and just trying to figure out
okay what are the dynamics and
you know who are the alphas and who's
taking charge and who's just like the
wallflower sitting on the edge and how
do you make decisions thought process
that kind of stuff it was a really cool
experience long story short i didn't get
picked
why don't you think you got picked um
i don't know i really don't know i i
sought out a couple of the judges that i
had
developed a little bit of a rapport with
to kind of get some feedback and
and this was part of the thing like
every step of the way people who were
former white house fellows who had given
me some mentorship on how to approach
the process
in advance and and some of the judges
like uh they're like oh you're shooting
like you were exactly the kind of person
that this program was built for
and um and so i um
stupidly had started to believe all of
that
and uh you know went through it and was
careful and did my preparation and went
into it
but you know in my mind i had already
told myself like
you got this like you're in and then
so when i was i was writing the metro in
dc
and i remember getting off at union
station and coming up the escalator and
then my phone buzzed
with a voicemail of course i was waiting
for the call
and uh the voicemail said hi tulsi
we regret to inform you
and so for that moment i was just like
i i was i was incredibly disappointed
obviously
um but then had to reset be like okay so
like that's off the table
um and so i ended up i ended up
uh you know i knew that i i was
continuing to see what what can i do and
i ended up running for uh and getting
elected to the honolulu city council
and focusing on those potholes and
you know trash and sewers and parks and
law enforcement
um for two years until
my former boss senator akaka retired
from the u.s senator announced he was
retiring
and the uh one of the members of
congress
said that she was going to run for his
seat which left a vacancy in the house
and ultimately that's that's where i
made the decision
um i made the decision to run knowing
that
specifically in the united states
congress i would be exactly
where i needed to be to try to influence
and impact those decisions
was it a tough campaign i mean it's
incredibly tough who
who you're going against there were six
people who ran
you know it's strong democratic state so
the real election is the primary
election
and there were six people who were
running in that democratic primary
but the main person who was kind of the
assumed winner of the election even you
know
nine months out from the election was a
guy who had
just run for and lost a race for
governor
but who is also the former mayor of oahu
the city and county of honolulu
and so you know just for some
perspective our state has about
1.4 million population
around 980 000 of which live on oahu
and the district that that we were
running for um
there's there's two members of congress
from hawaii one is kind of the urban
representative that that has almost the
whole south shore of oahu the urban that
kind of densely urban populated area
and then the other member of congress
which was the seat that i was running
for
has um the west side north shore and
east side of oahu and all of the
neighbor islands
and so i came into this uh
with i think it was about two percent
known name recognition in that district
because my city council district was
actually in the other um
it was in the urban part of oahu so
there was again no overlap in those
districts
and the guy you know the front runner in
the race he had everybody in the state
knew who he was
he also had a little bit of baggage um
that came with having just
been the mayor and uh that's a whole
other
whole other conversation but uh so so
the the challenge was
was pretty great to go from like three
like three percent against 100
and somehow i had to try to cover that
gap
um and i just you know i remember
meeting with with some some of the
the political um
you know elders for lack of a better
word in hawaii and letting them know
that
people i had decent relationships with
letting him know that i was going to run
and and
why and getting a lot of patronizing
responses back
saying you know tulsi you're i think i
was 30 at the time
31 you're young
you have no chance against this guy
so just you know don't waste your time
and
come back and try again in like 20 years
you'll be great in 20 years
and i was like i don't operate on that
timeline so you were like holding my
beer
pretty much pretty much did you just go
super aggressive how did
how the hell did you make up that kind
of distance well so first i i had to
um fundraising is a huge thing because
i needed to be able to have the
resources to
let people know i existed and who i am
first of all just my name
period and then to let them know you
know my experience and my background and
why
why i was wanting to serve them in
congress and
so you know we started out we started
out just like putting signs up
around the district and hoping that that
would
cause for people to say who's tulsi
gabbard like
what is this about and um and and
it was it was a lot of time
going and doing what what i called the
most extensive job interview
ever where i went traveled to each
island and spent a lot of time in
communities
with individuals with groups small
groups large groups
introducing myself to them and answering
their questions
and letting them know why i wanted to
serve them in congress what kind of
leadership
i would bring where i stood on on
different issues that they cared about
and um ultimately what happened was
five months before election day my i i
was pulling at 20 to the front runners
and then the rest was split between the
other people
and i was like awesome progress
exactly and i just i i just continued
you know i was
i was on the phone and i was asking
people for support and raising money and
then also
out on the road just you know seven days
a week all day
and uh it was it was it was an
incredible incredible experience
election day comes around uh in august
of
2012. and
all the way up until about two weeks
before the election
the local media and even some of the
national coverage was just like
this guy's this guy's got it i had heard
from other people he was already
interviewing staff
a few months before the election that he
planned to hire once he won
um our debate we had one
big televised debate we had a few others
but there was one big
televised debate i passed him in the
hall
right before the debate and he was
singing that song um
black eyed peas i think tonight's gonna
be
a good night as he looked back at me
and and i will i will um i have been
told i killed it in the debate
and that was where a lot of people first
started to take notice like who is she
and um i think i think it may
have caught him by surprise just a
little bit
but still like all the way up until
about two weeks before it was like he's
got it and then some of the polls
started to shift and some of the local
news they were like hold
wait this can't be right these polls
can't be right because you can't see a
big turn around
i ended up winning the primary election
going from that 20
five months before to actually beating
him by a 22
margin on election day and
it was it was uh people
people in dc like the next day they're
like okay
like what scandal caused him to to
allow you to win essentially or what was
the
thing that you know that happened and it
was it was
there was none it was literally
um i think the difference between
someone who felt
they were entitled to the position
because of a number of reasons
and and me recognizing what the position
really is it's a position of trust and
responsibility
that is is granted to you by
the voters in the state and they are the
ones who i'm accountable to and who i
work for
and um it was just it was it was a
it was a our local kind of walter
cronkite anchor of our news station
who's been doing
it forever longer than i've probably for
about 30 or 40 years he's still
on tv now he's a vietnam veteran
and that election night he was reporting
the results and he actually started to
get choked up and and got a little got a
little tearful
because he understood
why i was running bringing that
experience of service and having been
deployed
and the significance of
that i was going to congress not
for myself but that i was bringing my
brothers and sisters in uniform with me
uh and and um it was
it was it was a heavy night i mean it
was you know there were
parties and things going on but um i
remember leaving the the hall that night
on election night
and my sister was walking out with me
and she's like tulsi
you know you're allowed to celebrate you
know you're allowed to be happy about
this
but i was just i was immediately like
okay all right these are the results
what are we waking up and doing tomorrow
what's the next task what do we have to
do now in order to make sure that we
we hit our next mark and that's um
and and that's kind of the the focus
that i
that i carried with me throughout is you
know i'm not entitled to anything
and i am here only because
the people in my community in my home
state
have trusted me to to work for them and
to to be their voice and
and um to represent them to the best of
my ability
so the the hype of you winning that and
come being the being the underdog
champ rolling into d did that that kind
of came to you to dc
right i mean that that hype there's some
hype train yeah
from tulsi hype train i like saying that
so the tulsi hype train shows up and
you're
sort of um you're
viewed i think it's actually nancy
pelosi
called you like a rising star which is
you seem to hear that okay it's not like
it doesn't get thrown around
that term doesn't get thrown around
about political people
but you were like a quote rising star
in the democratic party so you came with
some hype
yeah i didn't i didn't fully understand
why
but yeah it was there i mean i had you
know she
i was actually making up drill time with
the national guard
after that primary election um
i remember being at my unit and she
called my my cell phone i
hadn't talked to her before and she
called my cell phone and left a message
and
introduced herself and just said hey you
know we have a democratic convention
coming up in a few weeks
i would love to have you come and be one
of the featured speakers during prime
time
as um and speak about
veterans let me know if you're
interested
and so again like that's not an
opportunity
that one gets when you've just been
elected
to congress to go and speak to i don't
know 50
000 people in an arena in the whole
country yes the whole it's everybody
yeah and uh and so you know i mean i i
was
grateful for the opportunity and and
went and um
it kind of yeah and then you know
shortly after getting sworn in as a
member of congress i was asked hey will
you be vice chair of the dnc and
like what what does a vice chair do um
what is what is actually that you're
asking me to do and and
what what can i do in that sense
that's what they're asking you to do
it's freaking weird right this is all
they they kind of saw you they saw
a good horse to put money into and
invest into a great story
and they they wanted to get some control
over that hype train
yeah and i think use you know
be able to say hey you know there are i
mean there are biographical boxes that i
checked a lot of boxes for you know the
diversity
uh pick the diversity higher
and and you know for me i'm i'm you know
just coming into each of these
experiences com
completely clear-eyed and not getting
googly-eyed at all like oh my god they
love me so much
but just recognizing okay like
what do you what are you trying to use
me for even
uh what do you get out of this and then
for me thinking okay like weighing
pros and cons and saying is this an
opportunity that i can use to try to get
some
some good done and if it is then
okay that makes sense like maybe there's
a mutually beneficial thing
here and if there's not then you know no
thanks
um but yeah that's that's that's where
that's where things started
so they started off like really awesome
yeah hey you've got all this hype you've
got
opportunities they're looking at you as
a
as a potential kind of horse to
put money into and invest into as long
as
we can control you on the track right
that's the fine print at what point did
you
did when was the first sort of uh time
that you kind of bucked a little bit
do you remember what it was yeah
absolutely it was my first year in
congress in 20 summer of 2013.
um every year in congress and i i don't
know
i think this may date back to pre-air
conditioning days
but every year in august congress goes
into recess
it's the hottest year of the month it's
you know dc is a literal actual
like geographical swamp and
um so you go you go back to your
you so you go back to your district
everybody in the house and the senate
there's a recess in august you go back
to your district and you get like four
or five weeks
at home or to go and do a congressional
delegation trip to another country or
whatever you set that space and time to
do that
and so i remember being home and getting
word that
president obama wanted to go and launch
airstrikes and a military attack in
syria
and um
i was filling up gas in my car
one i i so i started to get a lot of
calls from constituents from people
about this and this is where this is
very quickly developing i don't have all
the facts or information or intelligence
or anything at that point
but um people were concerned
and i was filling up i was filling up
gas one day um in
kapolei and and a woman who pulled up
her car next to me she saw me there and
she
came and walked over and she grabbed my
arm she's like tulsi
you know my kids in the military
please don't do this
because i don't understand what it's for
and and there was a number of other
kinds of messages coming from people
just either expressing total opposition
or concern
and just coming out of like you know
iraq and just every everything that had
led to that kind of
cynicism and fatigue or okay well you
want to go start another war in another
country
like what what did they do to us and
so the recess time was cut short i was
on the foreign affairs committee at that
time
and i was throughout most of the time i
was in congress and so we got called
back
to dc early so that we could go through
and get the intelligence briefings and
actually
get gather the information and that was
when i first started to take kind of a
deep dive into
what was happening in syria and why he
was proposing this and
ultimately after
going into the issue and the question
and and really
he was not going to come to congress at
first but then
uh enough members of congress said you
can't like the constitution does not
allow you to unilaterally just start a
war
you have to come and get congressional
approval for that
um and so that's we went back and
started to prepare for that that vote
that would happen
and i just i came to the conclusion
after studying the facts that it would
be a counterproductive
military action and much of it came from
and we had hearings with secretary
then secretary of state kerry and others
at the time
who were trying to tell congress like
well you know
this is not going to be a pin prick
strike but it's not going to be a
decapitation
it's going to be a punch in the gut and
you know some of my follow-up questions
were like okay so you're going to go
and deliver a punch in the gut attack
how will they respond oh you know
we don't really know but we don't think
it'll be a big deal okay
who are their friends who are they gonna
call
for help and how may they respond
how could this potentially escalate
into something that is no longer a punch
in the gut
but something that first second third
fourth order of effects
their response will require response
from us which require a response and all
of you know the the tit for tat
that then begins once you go over and
say
i'm not going to cut your head off i'm
just going to punch you in the gut and
think that you're not going to do
anything in response and i just saw so
many of the similarities of a
lack of foresight and
strategic planning and for me again as
military officer
basic level like military decision
making process
and actually thinking through these
things
and i saw similarity like this could
very easily become another
kind of iraq kind of situation where you
start making these decisions
and then they're on the fly and then
you're not realizing or thinking through
what do we do tomorrow
and then the next day and and where do
we go from here
and oh so i uh i wrote
i wrote like uh an opinion piece
expressing my opposition to the
president president obama's proposal
um published it and um
was the first democrat to do so to
express opposition to his proposal
and very quickly got a call from the
white house
basically saying how dare you who in the
it was the
the first lady's chief of staff and i
i still to this day scratch my head
about why
they asked her i knew her and maybe that
was just simply the reason why
but i would think that on a matter like
this
you would want to have i don't know
maybe a national security director
secretary like i don't know somebody but
that was that was essentially the
messages how dare you
no not only as a democrat but because
like you're from the president's home
state how could you
how could you so publicly disagree with
him on something oh that's right you
guys should have been hawaiians
but the thing was jaco is is nowhere in
that conversation
was the substance of the issue
raised like hey here's why we think your
opposition is
misplaced or here's what you're not
seeing or here's what
nothing yeah nothing at all you know
i wrote down while you were talking
what's the commander's intent like what
are we trying to do here because if you
can't tell me what it is
why we're going to do what we're doing
then we need to talk about it more
yeah that that's number one and
you know as you just put it the reason
why why are we doing something
why are we doing it and by the way i
tell people all the time if you work for
me
and we're doing something that you don't
know why we're doing it you raise your
hand and you say hey jacqueline why the
hell are we doing this and i say well
here's why
and you say well that doesn't make any
sense and i go please explain that to me
then
so that i can make a better decision
because if if i can't get my team on
board then i must be
i must not be seeing something or i'm
not explaining
my perspective well enough that they can
go oh yeah got it jocko thank you and we
now understand that thank you
that's number one number two so when you
fire off this article is that a good
tactical move for you
in other words you know would it may
may it have been a better move to say
hey listen i need to talk to
you know you tell your friend the the
first lady's chief of staff listen
i want some clarification i don't want
to get crazy here but look i just got
back from iraq a few years ago
it gets bad it gets ugly we got to make
sure we know what we're doing
can can we have a further conversation
because i
no one seems to be listening to me right
now and it's a problem
i chose to take that public course of
action
because i had just gone through
days of
internal discussions q a
expressions of concern and ex
essentially expressed all of those same
points of opposition
internally to members of the
administration
and saw that nothing was nothing was
breaking through
and that the answers that they were
delivering
were pretty canned
and set and that there was not
real there was not really an interest of
a discussion or a response
like of introspection saying hey maybe
we're missing something here
and or maybe we're not communicating
clearly or
you know it was just like this is it
this is what we're doing
and the why like why what are you trying
to accomplish well we need to send a
message
okay send a message
and then what like you can like
communication's a two-way street
i can send you a message but if if i
want that message to be effective like i
need to anticipate how you might respond
and so there was i i chose the course of
action that i chose
purely because i felt i had exhausted um
internal or maybe kind of back channel
means of addressing
those concerns it seems like what did
you also
sort of had already done an
assessment to think like these people
don't listen yeah
this wasn't this wasn't just one day you
decided you know what that's it i'm
gonna fire off this article
it's a pre-existing condition that is
when people say hey i got an issue with
this we get told shut up
get get on board with the program that's
what we're gonna do so you had already
experienced that
yeah so i mean this this in this
specific situation
it was not so there were other democrats
who
who shared these and republicans who
shared these concerns um
and that were raising these questions
within the hearings both both
public and and closed um hearings
so it wasn't like hey we expect
everybody to
like there was not a pressure coming
from the democratic leadership in this
example saying hey we expect you to toe
the line on this and just support
this because it's president obama so
this was not that kind of
situation there are other examples of
that
but yeah it just
it was clear it was clear that
the message that was coming from the
administration was was really
um it was kind of a one-way
communication
and and so i knew enough to know that
when when they they're kind of locked
and loaded in in their position the only
thing that
may cause them to change or to budge is
public pressure and that's ultimately
what happened
it it the public pressure was bipartisan
and and and reached such a volume
that they never even brought the vote to
congress because they knew it would be
an abject
failure and and the the
the military action never happened
and obama got criticized for that
because i don't know if you remember but
he
this was like this was a red line right
like okay
and he got vastly criticized by
republicans and i think some democrats
like how
how dare you not enforce your own red
line
um and i still you know i think this was
one of um
ultimately the final decision that he
made i it was the right decision because
because of all the reasons that i felt
it was the wrong decision to to make in
the first place but also it forced him
to take a diplomatic path to resolve the
issue that he was trying to address
um which is you know hey like maybe that
should have been your first
first primary course of action yeah
don't paint yourself into a corner yeah
exactly just like don't don't put
yourself in a situation in a combat
scenario where you can't maneuver don't
do that
don't don't put your you know don't
don't put your back against a cliff
where you can't go anywhere else
yes don't don't do that it's not a good
move it's not a good tactical move it's
not a good strategic move
there's you know this this whole thing
when i when i ask you these questions
one of the things that
well you're gonna i know i know you just
told me you were reading about face
right now well
the crux of about spoiler alert in about
face he ends up at the end of the
vietnam
war well it's not the end of vietnam war
it's the end of his vietnam war he goes
and gets interviewed
and says we're gonna lose if we don't
change the way we're fighting
and of course he gets drummed out of the
army in a matter of months
you know it's all bad and the question
that i always
kind of consider is well if he would
have
kept his mouth shut he would have had
you know he would have had a brigade he
would have had a division he would have
had the influence of all
many many more soldiers and much more
strategy and
and could have perhaps steered the war
in a better direction
if he would have played the game more
now there's an emotional component to it
which is completely understandable which
is that hackworth
absolutely loved the army and he loved
his soldiers
and he was seeing soldiers get killed
and wounded every single day and he got
to a point where
he it wasn't unacceptable to him
we had a similar thing you know that you
and i were talking about with
general mattis and at what point
you know if general mattis who's so
highly respected
and just smart and
and and
resolute in his beliefs and
and kind of unflappable so it was really
nice when he got appointed i was so
happy i'm like okay we got some sanity
going on here we got somebody that's
that's rational right very rational guy
and it's at one point it's over and then
you wonder okay
hey look i know it sucked and i know you
didn't like it but
don't you have more influence when
you're sitting in the seat
that's that's that's a an issue that
people
leaders have to deal with on all
different levels you know i talk about a
lot in leadership strategy and tactics
not a lot but i write a section about it
yeah
if you're my boss and you tell me hey
jocko i want you to do this mission
here and i say well i don't think it's a
good mission
and i think you know it's going to cause
casualties or i don't think it's got a
good strategic objective or
and you say i jocko you do what i told
you and i say but
hey you know ma'am it doesn't seem like
a good plan to me and you say hey jaco
shut up and do it
now i can either draw a line in this
hand and say i'm not going to do it and
then what do you do
you fire me you put echo in charge and
echo goes it goes and does it because
he's just a yes man
so now but i've given up all my
influence at that point which is not
good
there's a scene in band of brothers dick
winters
who gets ordered to do a reconnaissance
it's the end of the war and he goes i
don't really think that's a good idea
the colonel says shut up and do it he
goes okay
he goes and does it they get a guy
killed they come back the next night
the the colonel says i want you to do
another recon tomorrow night
and dick winter says i don't think
that's a good idea the war is almost
over we lost a guy yesterday
and he goes shut up and do it and he
says roger that sir and they go to a
basement and they drink wine what'd you
see on the recon we didn't see anything
okay good you know he
he went along with it but he still had
some control and this is just a hard
thing and it's
it's interesting to hear your
perspective of
you know at some point you make a stand
and that's where you decided to make a
stand and
obviously you lose some influence after
you did that you lost some you know i
don't know how many
invites you got to those dinners after
you did that it's probably not a high
number
so you give up some influence but at the
same time you're you're
you're holding the line on what you
believe in yeah
and at some point you've got to do that
i mean at some point you go look
tulsi i don't care you want me to do
this mission it's a bad idea we
shouldn't do it and if you got to fire
me fire me
yeah and maybe that's me just trying to
send you a message
maybe you say oh geez jocko's really
serious i must really have a bad
i must really have a bad perspective of
what i'm trying to get this guy to do
because he's never said no to me and now
he's saying no to me
all right jocko tell me your reasons
again and now we can have a conversation
tough tough those are tough things
for leaders to do yeah and that then
they're
if if you i would say this is
especially true in politics but i think
it's probably applicable across the
board
is if you know
what you are trying to accomplish
ultimately what's the greater goal
and your goal is not about
self-preservation if your goal
is not selfishly motivated but instead
um you know how how can i serve this
this greater purpose that you're
obviously there to do
then um you're able to more
unemotionally and clearly assess okay
here i've got three different options
here
here's where this one leads here's where
that one leads here's where that one
leads
and assess okay you know what what
really ultimately what is going to help
me get help help get me closer to that
thing that i'm trying to accomplish
and um i've i've gone through many
many iterations of this as i've made
different decisions that had very
serious political consequences and that
um especially the big ones were were
very
often the unpopular decision that people
were kind of scratched their head like
what what is wrong with her like
she's she's she's going and doing things
that nobody does she's going and saying
things that nobody will say
is she crazy or just stupid or what
um but if you take a step back you know
really
uh who am i accountable
to and what is my purpose if my purpose
is to be a part of the
um to seek the approval of of the
elite in washington then i would have
made completely different decisions
completely from the from the get-go uh
and i would have done very different
things
but if my accountability is to end
it is and and has been to the people who
elected me
to serve if my accountability is to our
brothers and sisters in uniform both
those who continue to serve
those who have laid down the uniform and
those who have paid the ultimate price
then i'm making my decisions through a
different
lens in a different context than folks
are used to
in washington and it's not to say like
hey i'm just going gangbusters and i'm
going to go run through a freaking brick
wall no matter what the consequence
and it it is being clear-eyed about okay
here here are the here are the potential
ramifications to this
and sometimes they are known and
sometimes they are an unknown factor
but ultimately these major decision
points that i have come across
um do the right thing
if you don't if you don't know and
you're not sure and all of these like
ultimately
do the right thing because it's the
right thing
and even even as you may get you know
um the you know
the political fire or the the negative
consequences or these other things like
ultimately whether it takes a little
time or it takes a long time doing the
right thing is always the right thing
and i'm you know i'm i'm
[Music]
able to know that wherever my path goes
i've done my best
to make that best decision when faced
with
hard right easy wrong
the i used to tell my guys if you're
doing the right things for the right
reasons
you we will win in the end exactly so if
we're doing the right things for the
right reasons we'll win in the end now
what's interesting about this is
you know you on certain occasions to
some extent you didn't play the game
right and as you just said you know you
played the game sometimes and you
did what you had to do and formed those
relationships and then sometimes you
didn't play the game
and this is what's interesting and that
this is where the future's unknown where
does that lead
if you were doing the right things for
the right reasons which you were
ultimately you'll win in the long run we
don't know what that looks like yet
right at some point i know it's like a
big gamble right
because we could paint an entire
entirely different picture of tulsi that
went to
washington played the game said the
right things vote the right votes
nodded the head and you'd be in a
different spot than you are right now
you'd be you could potentially i mean
from your trajectory when you look at
you in 2012 is that when you showed up
when you showed up in 2012 your
trajectory was steep
and like you said you checked various
boxes that
needed to be checked and if you would
have played the game that whole time you
could be in a position
you know you could be president right
now you could be president right now
having conformed to what you were being
told to do
now we don't know where this actually
ends up right because it's
it's 2020. we don't know where this ends
up maybe people will be listening to
this in
2039 or whatever and they'll be going oh
yeah jocko called
it jocko called it you did the right
thing for the right reason to look at
how it turned out
that could potentially happen but of
course you know a bunch of other things
happen too
but it's it's something that we have to
struggle with as leaders
doing if but if i still believe this and
i tell people this all the time
if you're doing the right things for the
right reasons you're going to win in the
end
in the end you are going to win it might
take
years it might take i guess it could
take decades when you're talking about
this these types of decisions but the
other
component of this is which i think in my
just just from sitting here
looking at you as you're talking about
this
you every day have to look yourself in
the mirror yep
and at a certain point you say
i'm not going to do that and again
look there's i always tell people play
the long tank play the long game think
strategic
i i tell people i would say when people
ask me oh i got some situation at work
and my boss told me to do this
all the time i'd give the i give you the
advice play the game oh tulsi wants me
to do this paperwork and she's been
yelling at me to do it
and it doesn't make any sense for me to
do this paperwork i tell that's that's
awesome
yeah do the paperwork play the game
build a good relationship with tulsi so
you can
actually talk to her in the future and
explain why that paperwork doesn't make
sense right
play the game until you get to a point
where you got to look at yourself
in the mirror and you can't
and then you're not doing the right
thing and you're not doing it for the
right reasons
and you got to make a different decision
yeah
yeah i um that that's exactly right and
in order to do that it's being able to
have not lost your foundation and your
groundedness
so that you have the ability to be
introspective
and to know what actually matters
versus the things that that don't really
matter
which help you determine you know which
battles am i going to pick
to fight and also
um what is what it what is winning how
do you define
winning is it is it a specific
title or is it a specific position
or when you say do the right things for
the right reasons and
at some point in time sooner or later
you're gonna win
for me in my case that that's that is a
hundred percent
true i think what
um maybe is not obvious
to people is winning is not becoming
president united states
winning is not becoming a united states
senator or a member of congress
or an ambassador or whatever pick
pick the job pick the crappy job
[Laughter]
you have a different perspective than
most people in washington who live their
lives
from college to try to strategically
plan their lives to get these jobs
yeah except for the fact that you know
winning
you know look if you're the president
you have a massive you have the most
amount of influence that you could
possibly
have i used to tell that to these young
seal officers it's like
oh you're going to kiss ass to get
promoted well if you kiss ass
quote to get promoted guess what you can
take better care of your troops
which is why you're here right that's
why we're here to take care of our team
be able to accomplish the mission
so sometimes it's like oh those are
those are aligned
winning when i'm a platoon commander
instead of a
e5 and a platoon i have more influence
over that situation so i can do a better
job of the mission i can do a better job
attacking the enemy and i can do a
better job of taking care of the guys
that work for me that's all good and you
know what i had to sit through some
meetings and i had to nod my head and i
had to support my
whatever commanding officer or my master
chief when they told me to do something
that didn't make quite make sense but i
did it
why not so i could get promoted that's
the big difference not so i could get
promoted and i never did
it was as you know for me it was such a
it made my career so much easier
because i never was worried about
getting promoted i never cared if i got
promoted
and it actually helped it helped because
i was doing the right things for the
right reasons and
my bosses would look at me and say like
yeah this guy cares about the guys and
he wants to get the mission done let's
get him promoted yeah i wasn't doing it
to get promoted
it's just gonna happen if you're doing
the right things for the right reasons
so there's a weird dichotomy there
no winning isn't necessarily getting
promoted or becoming the president or
whatever the case may be
but if you're looking to have the most
amount of influence that take care of
your people and your troops and your
country and your nation
that's a really good spot to be in and
that that the order of that i think is
the most important thing because
too often in politics people get so
attached to the position or the title
and their right their entire identity is
wrapped around that whether they have it
or it is their ambition to achieve that
position or title
that they forget that the real goal is
being in a position of impact and
influence
where you can serve and make that
positive impact
and that's where for me even from when i
ran for state house
through the different political
positions that i've had like i had no
issue and no qualms about walking away
from
what was beginning what was the
beginning of some would say would be an
illustrious political career as
a 21 year old elected of the state house
when it came for that decision point are
you going to stay are you going to go
i went because i wasn't losing anything
and like people oh you're gonna give up
this political career you've only just
begun
i'm not giving up anything i am only
choosing at this point to serve in a
different way
and i think that's when we look at when
i've thought about okay well
you know winning winning is being in
that position of impact and influence
and and maybe at some point it does
take that form of you know serving an
elected office in a high position
where i can execute on that or maybe it
takes a different form or a different
shape
you know for the time being or for
whatever it is
it's staying it that the order of that
staying focused okay
this is the goal and the position and
the platform
that i may have at a different point in
time to accomplish that goal doesn't
change the goal
did you underestimate the power of the
swamp
maybe a little bit
but i think
even yeah i would say yeah i mean the
the power of
the political infrastructure and the
party system and how much
money uh in you know there are limits
like
if i'm well if when i ran for president
ran for congress there are limits like
if you wanted to make a political
contribution to me
you know the limit changes every
election but let's say it's two thousand
dollars that's all you can give
there's no there's no real limit to what
you can give to either political party
so if you wanted to write a two million
dollar check you could do that no
problem
and so if you look at the the balance of
power
that gives the political parties a heck
of a lot of power
to to leverage um
over a specific candidate or specific
incumbent
and to use as using the power plays that
are used so that that was something that
that um i came into and i think was was
unexpected so just to clarify this i can
give two thousand dollars to tulsi for
congress
right but i can give two million dollars
to
the democratic next 200 million or
whatever yep
and therefore the party has that money
yes and now they can dole it out
to the people that are playing involved
with the program that are playing the
game
yep and it's a little surprising
to you it was a little surprising yeah
that how much control they had
and and seeing it play out literally on
the house floor
when votes or votes are happening or
what is it about to happen
it's like hey where is this member of
congress i heard
he or she is thinking of voting with
republicans
we need to find him and
talk to them and uh get them in line
and they say and there are actual jobs
like i don't have you seen house of
cards
yeah you're fine don't don't worry about
it
but but it's featured in this show house
of cards the the
um the main character he kind of starts
out he's a member of congress
and he is uh the whip and
the position is literally called the
whip and um
that's their job is they whip votes
and so if somebody's so i go to you and
i say hey tulsi i know you're kind of
wavering on this vote but it looks like
you got a tough race coming up there in
hawaii
could use some extra tv advertisement
don't you think
yeah it's like that like for real that's
it that's how it is yeah
kind of or that's how it works um
it takes different sometimes it can be
very direct like that uh i
i th this is so this is something that
that
um i have not personally directly been
the target of
because they knew partially because i i
got elected without any help
from the democratic party locally or
nationally
um there was no fundraising help there
was no
hey we're gonna push you know it was a
primary election and
generally they don't get involved in
primary elections it's not
it's not a rule that's always followed
but in my case it was
and because it's such a strong
democratic state generally they'll use
their resources to help
democrats get elected or re-elected in
swing districts or republican districts
if they're like ah
tulsi you're good like we don't have to
worry about you
in my case then that also means there's
no leverage
from them uh but i have friends who i've
served with who are in those positions
where
you know a re-election in a
congressional race like they've got to
raise
10 million 20 million bucks which is
you know in my race i think i raised i
raised about i don't know
a little over a million dollars um
so for them there is a lot of leverage
and it's used
it's certainly used to to try to get
you as a member of congress to do what
the what is best for the party
rather than what you believe is the
right thing to do based on your
conscience and based on how you feel you
can best serve
yeah what's the percentage
that they're able to wield that
sledgehammer
effectively like how much control i mean
it's it's
it's pervasive and so that that's one
example is hey you've got you you're
always
you've got a tough re-election or a
tough race or a tough challenge or
whatever
that's one approach and the other
approach is people who are interested in
climbing the
the ladder and so you will either have
a cherry opportunity placed before you
or maybe you won't have that opportunity
presented or it'll be taken away
so you know it's kind of like you know
they'll look at okay what does this
person want
and what do they need and how can we
use that as a motivator to try to get
them to do
uh what we want them to do and so this
is the imbalance
that needs to be corrected in our
political system where this idea of
hey anybody can go and run for congress
and i know that my member of congress is
always going to go and act in my best
interest as a voter
has unfortunately become so twisted into
this thing that is about
one party versus the other party and
it's always about the next election
and how they can battle and who is gonna
win
rather than how do we work together and
actually solve
problems and pass meaningful legislation
and i you know i again early on you know
there were there were some republicans
um
obamacare right hugely divisive issue
politically that's been weaponized
by both sides issue of health care and
there were some republic we found like
hey here are some easy fixes this was
this was uh
when i was elected in 2012 obamacare was
passed in 2010.
and so i you know there were some
democrats and republicans we started to
say hey
let's figure out what we can do together
like we're this is we're here in
congress this is why we are here
and there were some easy um
uh kind of very simple common sense
corrections that we could make uh it
through legislation to this bill
that are no brainers like not not
controversial at all common sense
no-brainers
exactly okay sounds good good set up i
like it and have that work out
it turns out that both party leadership
um indirectly expressed opposition
to this idea and what we were
talking about doing on the democratic
side
because it would require that they would
have to admit
that the bill had some flaws that needed
fixing
and on the republican side opposed to it
because
if you fix obamacare then what do you
run against
what do you criticize the other side for
if you actually fix
it in a way that it it helps
people and if people start to like it
then you can't raise money off of it and
you can't weaponize it
for political purposes and
that's that that was 2013.
and unfortunately here we are in 2021
and it has only
progressively escalated and gotten far
worse far divisive to the point where as
we sit here today you have the speaker
of the house nancy pelosi referring to
republicans as quote unquote the
enemy within
the enemy within and the implications of
that
like the actual legitimate implications
of that were as
when you make that statement that you
do not trust people from the opposing
party broadly she's not saying hey this
one person
i feel is a threat to our security and
needs to be reported to law enforcement
that's a different story if that if that
were the case
we have systems within our government to
do that if you think a member of
congress
poses a security threat to their
colleagues
report it to law enforcement do it
but to throw this out in a public
setting i think it wasn't a press
conference she said that
that they are the enemy within uh and
other democrats saying
i don't feel safe around my republican
colleagues
what you're saying is that if any member
and any democrat goes
and tries to have a conversation with or
reach out to or work with
a republican they are working with the
enemy they are collaborating with the
enemy
they are now traitors to
who i mean to the country to democrats
where does that then lead and how is
there
any possibility
of healing
and unifying and reaching out
to get past the inflammatory
divisive state that we're in
okay so we got that going for us
it seems like uh well i i didn't
track every move that you made but
certainly one of the
uh if not at least from what i know
the biggest kind of move that you made
that was outside the system is when you
went against
hillary in 2016
for for president is that is that was
that the
straw that broke the camera it was a big
one that was a big one
um yeah and that was one of those that
was one of those big decision points
that i had um where
i couldn't i couldn't map out what the
actual consequences to that decision
would be so you knew i knew what
happened i i knew
no i i knew i obviously knew it was it
was a serious decision that would have
serious implications but exactly what
those implications would be
i i didn't i didn't know um
i had different political advisors and
people who
you know who knew washington and who
knew me giving me
very serious warning and just saying
look tulsi this could be the end of the
political road for you potentially
so just know that before you make this
decision and
and just just to back up a little bit
why the back story that led to my making
that decision was
i was still vice chair of the dnc at
that point
and as an officer of the dnc the rules
say you have to be neutral in a primary
election that the dnc's role is to make
sure that the primary election process
is um executed in a fair
in a fair way so that voters have the
opportunity to make their decision
on who they would like to be the
democratic nominee to become the
president united states
and so that was my like okay i'm going
to make sure that i fulfill that
responsibility and make sure that
our democratic process works in uh
in this primary and i had no plans to
get involved
in the race at all and there were
you know there were a number of you know
this wasn't the reason why i ultimately
made the decision but there were a
number of issues that started to
um present themselves
in seeing that the chair of the dnc at
that time
was making unilateral decisions about
how the primary process would work
that made it very clear that it would
not be fair
or neutral and that those the process
decisions that were being made would
favor hillary clinton over any other
candidate
and i and other officers of the dnc
expressed privately and then our
concerns in opposition
a to the fact that like hey like we're
officer the dnc
you're asking us to attach our names to
decision that you as the chair made but
we had absolutely no discussion or input
to it whatsoever and i'm not comfortable
doing that and then when seeing there
was no
it was kind of like okay no like i don't
care i don't care the decision's been
made and
that's it and then airing some of those
concerns publicly
for the purpose of trying to bring some
accountability and
transparency to the process and just two
just two two examples one was um
limiting the initial decision that that
the chairman made or the chairwoman made
was
there would only be six debates in the
primary election
and to me that was ridiculous like there
had never been so few debates
um ever and why why that number of
debates mattered was because of the
second decision that was made which was
if any candidate participated
in a non-dnc sanctioned
debate or forum they would be banned
from participating in
any future dnc debate so you'd be
punished
for actually seeking out opportunities
to talk to voters
um both of those decisions seemed
pretty undemocratic to me while we're
standing here saying hey we want we want
high voter turnout we want people to
engage in the process we want people to
engage with the candidates
but we're only going to allow six
debates and if they do any debate or
forum that's not one of our six
then they won't be able to come and play
with us
at all because hillary had such good
name recognition
every one of these debates would be an
opportunity for someone else to get more
name recognition
yeah and challenge her track record i
mean actually god forbid have a real
dialogue in conversation and
a compare and contrast for voters on
each of you know i mean obviously bernie
sanders and hillary clinton were kind of
the two primary candidates but there
were a few others
who were still running at that time
martin o'malley was when he was the
governor of maryland and
and um so so that that was kind of
already happening but ultimately
as as this process um started to
to begin i saw how
even in these limited debate settings
how little attention was being focused
by the democratic party as well as their
their corporate media partners on
foreign policy
and on the the qualifications
that voters may look for in a
commander-in-chief
and what that responsibility meant
um it was just not it was you know they
were talking about a bunch of other
things
most most things that to me
like superficial political drama and
theater like not issues that really
mattered a whole lot
when you look at the implications on
people's everyday lives but
as a soldier obviously for me like this
is the
most well it's not just as a soldier the
most important responsibility that
that any president has is to serve as
commander in chief
you know our constitution very clear
like i can have all the economic
positions i want in positions on
education and positions on health care
as president i can't do anything
of great impact without working with
congress
and that's i mean that that's the it's
the check and balance that our
our founders had in mind for us which is
a good thing
but there's only one commander in chief
and it
ultimately drove me to resign as by
share of the dnc
and and endorse bernie sanders over
hillary clinton
because i saw a huge um
gap and difference contrast between the
two of them and
in hillary clinton's uh very
interventionist
kind of war hawk warmonger track record
uh both as secretary of state and and
as u.s senator versus bernie sanders
who through his time in service had
proven to have
more of a non-interventionist leaning
and be a little bit more critical in
questioning of
any rush to war and i you know
on a whole host of other issues i i
didn't uh you know bring i agree or
disagree on a number of other issues but
this was the singular issue that i made
my decision on
to to resign as vice chair of the dnc
and endorse bernie sanders so that i
would have a platform
to start to push to be a voice to push
this question and to challenge the media
and to bring to voters
here's the differences between the two
major candidates in this primary
you get to decide
what kind of commander-in-chief you want
and so um that was
you know i i announced that decision on
um
sunday show meet the press uh there in
washington
went to the studio um didn't tell them
really what i was there to announce it
was you know i i intentionally
kept this to myself very very close hold
knowing how incestuous the relationships
are between
politicians and the media and attempts
to try to
um undermine my ability to deliver my
message for myself
and so there are probably
like two people in my life who
knew what i was going to do i went
live television sunday morning shared my
decision
and why and then you know my phone
started ringing off the hook
literally i'm in the car rolling away
from the studio but
but the most stark response i got was um
and they ranged from like
tulsi that was a brave uh and
righteous decision to like yeah exactly
and that's what it was that was sunday
and then i think it was either monday or
tuesday we had votes and went back into
session in congress and
and um both democrats and republican
colleagues of mine were kind of coming
up and patting me on the back
saying that like nice knowing you um
have a good afterlife and
even even some democrats who who had um
like endorsed obama over hillary in 2008
early
like from the beginning and who shared
like hey
like i i made that decision and i was on
the clinton [ __ ] list for
years before i was able to dig myself
out of it
and tulsi don't you know that she's
going to win
and you're going to be on the list and
that there is a list
and what that means in a practical way
is
you don't get your bill signed into law
you don't get funding
for the things that you need or that
your constituents need
in your district and that your efforts
the reason why you are here and the
efforts that you are putting forward
will be
will be blocked and so you're rendering
yourself ineffective
because she will be president and um
that was that was the washington
response basically you're politically
dead
um you you knew that though right
yeah i took it to that level i i knew i
wasn't working i was
like i chuckled as people told me this i
was there was nothing there was nothing
that i heard the morning after that
did that surprised me i knew that the
race you kind of feel like a badass when
you walked into congress on monday
did you kind of i don't i'm not not
badass or did you feel like
no neither neither i i was i was
um i was amused at like
the hushed air for real
yeah for real for real no joke and like
the sideways glance is like
is it okay to go and talk to her now or
not and like i don't want to be you know
like thought to be i don't know part of
whatever she's doing like i don't know
like there's all these different things
and how about the fact that now like
whoever told you
hey now all the things you're going to
try to do are going to get squashed
you're not going to be able to make any
progress
here that's a real thing and so again
going back to this
strategic decision making
if you're trying to take care of your
constituents and you make
the worst enemy that you can have in dc
that's not good
well what what i what ended up happening
obviously is she did not win the
election
and some of those very same people who
remain good friends of mine who were
being honest with me then
saying you're politically finished then
came back to me later and said
well turns out you saw something
that nobody else saw at that time
so you know kudos to you for standing up
for your principles and what you believe
in and listening
to both your heart but also
recognizing where people in the country
are
rather than listening to the echo
chamber within washington
and yeah
so it so at that point you got a little
clout back
yeah yeah but it's all it's all not i
have the beholder
really i mean there there are there's
unquestionable that a lot of
the the challenges that i that i faced
as i was running for president
um can be traced back to that
original sin and just how how deep
you know yeah there there were certainly
ramifications
but also um it was i mean i had the
opportunity to to
raise the issues that i ran for congress
to raise and to bring them to the
forefront and to get conversations
starting
about you know the issues of war and
peace and
and when do when is it right to send our
troops into battle
and and um what questions should we be
asking as leaders in this country
before we make that decision and
recognize like i'm not a pacifist i'm
not a peacenik
i i care and have dedicated my adult
life to that
that service to protecting our national
security the safety of the american
people
i am just pushing to make sure that we
have leaders in this country who
recognize the seriousness
of of of
life and death of war
and peace and when
war may be actually necessary and
warranted
and knowing that our troops have
volunteered to go
knowing that that may mean a sacrificing
of their own lives and all of the
sacrifices that our loved ones and
families make
and don't think twice about it that's
what we sign up for
to serve our country
but also knowing that sometimes the
tougher
decision to make is to not go to war
the harder decision may be recognizing
that even as there may be a problem that
that
we want to solve in the world
that sometimes it it requires more
strength and courage to recognize a
it's a problem we can't solve b
it trying to do so
would not serve our national security
interests or the interests of
of the american people and therefore
recognizing that the right answer may be
to
to not do anything so
so really that's the other part of the
strategic
move is strategically it's going to make
you harder and it's going to make your
job harder in some respects after you
execute this move on on hillary but at
the same time it's going to bring these
important issues to light so
strategically
there's at an advantage and a
disadvantage yes and you weighed them
out and said you know what
if i don't bring these subjects to light
no one is going to do it
i could not i could not
i was not okay with sitting on the
sidelines and
watch this every presidential election
is important
there's not a single one every every
election this is the
most important election of our lifetimes
every single one is important
and i could not live with myself
if i had chosen to sit on the sidelines
and let this whole thing play out
without
doing my very best to insert
these most important questions and
issues and contrasting of records
into the dialogue and conversation so
that voters would have the ability to
make the best informed decision
possible
so then you decide you're going to run
when is that that's
what when do you figure that out when do
you figure out when do you say to
yourself you know what i need to run for
president
the
the event that triggered
um the event that ultimately led to my
making that decision
was the happened in january of 2018
and it was i'm sure you remember this
echo but it was
when on a saturday morning we got
a text alert sent out to every cell
phone in the state
civil defense alarms sounding saying
missile incoming to hawaii
seek immediate shelter this is not
a drill and
the aftermath of that where immediately
we're thinking like i've been working
the issue related to north korea
for a very long time for obvious reasons
that north korea is continuing to
develop their nuclear capabilities
they're developing their
intercontinental ballistic missile range
capabilities miniaturized nuclear
warheads
that that not only could reach hawaii
but could reach a significant portion of
the mainland at that time in 2018 now
they have continued to develop that and
they can reach anywhere in the country
but this is the scenario that's playing
out get this message
like north korea's is sending uh
you know a nuclear missile to us which
means we have
15 minutes to live
i i was in dc when this happened
um you know all my loved ones my family
everyone uh is is in hawaii and
what happened there was absolutely
terrifying where um
you know there was a video that came out
after it was an iphone video that
that this this father took
as he lowered his little eight-year-old
girl i think she was about eight years
old down a manhole
telling her that this is the only place
you'll be safe
and with the camera saying like
if if i don't make it you know at least
i want you to be okay
um there were countless countless
stories of people that i heard from
after this event happened about
about what they went through in you know
there was a guy
who he had like he had one of his kids
that was in town another kid that was on
the west side of the island
in waianae and he was somewhere in the
middle and in that moment got that
message
trying to decide which
am i going to drive to town or drive to
waianae which of my kids
am i going to try to get to to spend
those last minutes of my life with
you know mother's going in the bathtub
like seek seek immediate shelter
everyone's like where do i go friend of
mine he's got like a ton of kids i don't
know six or seven kids
he just started driving to the mountains
like i just got to go find a cave
somewhere
and but but there was no shelter
there's no shelter and so you got this
fancy alert system and
like okay it's blasting out see
community shelter there is there is no
shelter
um what what ended up happening in those
minutes that followed for me as soon as
i got that notification on my phone
i'm in dc i like
holy [ __ ] what is happening i need to
figure out what's happening
and so i just started like going through
okay i know that i can
probably try to reach indo pacom like
command
sell i don't have they don't bring cell
phones in the building so that's a
problem
i ended up uh the first person i called
was our state address in general
who i knew if something was happening he
was going to be at that civil defense
command and
he would obviously know and so i called
him and i said what's going on
he's also my boss in the national guard
so you know dual hat duel had there but
i called him and i said
what's going on and very quickly he said
it's a false alarm
i said i'm gonna put this out publicly
you're telling me this is a false alarm
and he said somebody push the wrong
button
false alarm so there's no missile coming
in no missile coming in
so i immediately hung up with him typed
out a tweet
in big block letters this is a false
alarm
i have confirmed with authorities there
is no missile incoming
and uh that tweet was the first
public notification that went out um
that let people know what was going on
but you know i just started
i was on the phone cons i was calling
news stations radio stations
you know uh people were calling me and i
just literally i was just like
false alarm click false alarm click just
trying to get let people know what was
going on and
there's a whole other you know like
incompetence thing like there was no
official notification to the public
coming from the state government
until 38 minutes after that initial
alert was sent out and that was a that
was a whole other issue but the thing
that led me
ultimately to make that decision like to
start thinking about i need to run for
president is because of
what everyone went through and realizing
that you can have this fancy alert
system and
i'm sure the governor and other people
are all bunkered down
somewhere safe but there's no safety or
shelter for anyone else
and ultimately
the fact that
people the fact that this is a real
threat
that exists and there are
others that
politicians have
created or escalated through political
rhetoric of heightening
tensions with nuclear-armed countries
of of spurring a nuclear arms race
and knowing like okay you know i'm sure
there's probably some
some mechanism or system in place to
protect them and their families but what
about everybody
else in the country people who
um i mean nuclear war ends and
utter complete destruction of the world
ultimately
and
having gone through what we went through
i wanted to be in a position to do two
things
by running for president i could raise
this issue and bring it to the forefront
because nobody was talking
about it maybe there was a day of of
you know cnn coverage or whatever on
what happened in hawaii but then it was
it was completely dropped and forgotten
there was no like hold on a second so
wait north korea has these capabilities
they're continually increasing this
threat is real
there is no shelter like if we get
attacked then it's kind of it's game
over
what what's being done about this by the
leaders and that none of that happened
at all even in the aftermath of
something that was
you know terrifying
and in such a real way and so so to be
able to address these issues
um and and the existential threat that
we face that comes from that
um continued advancement towards the the
brink of nuclear war that that
that we're on and if elected
to be in a position as
commander-in-chief
to begin to walk us back away from that
brink and to actually do something about
it to de-escalate these tensions to
actually work through the kinds of
negotiations and treaties that previous
presidents like
you know reagan and jfk did when they
recognized
the seriousness of what happens when you
when you are in a cold war and when you
have nuclear armed countries who either
intentionally or
accidentally can spark a nuclear war
that would result
in the end of of humanity on this planet
and uh that was that was the driver
for me to make that decision um to run
and unfortunately
i very quickly found out that
neither the media nor the politicians
were interested in talking about
it or anything that really mattered
that it was it was about
who's saying bad things about who
uh which candidate is um
you know who looks cool who's likable
who's all of these superficial things
but whether it was on the debate stage
when i raised these issues
or in interviews with reporters one on
one
or i mean i talked about i talked
obviously talked about these issues
every day multiple times a day town hall
meetings that reporters covered
or were present for at least with the
intent to cover what happened
there was no interest in in in talking
about
uh this specific issue about the
existential threat of nuclear war
and what how we got here and where we
need to go to prevent it
what to speak of of of other issues and
that was
that was the most frustrating um that
was the most frustrating thing about
about running for president was the
realization that
even as a candidate for president united
states
the ability to bring
such an issue as serious as this to the
american people
was so easily squashed by
the corporate entertainment media and um
the politicians who benefit from them
corporate entertainment media yeah
that's a good name for the news
it's it's more accurate than the news it
certainly is
so you said you realized very quickly
that
that no one wanted to hear about this
stuff yeah like when you say very
quickly
how long did it take before you looked
around and said wait a second
because i remember hearing about you i
mean maybe it was on rogan
um i i forget but i remember thinking oh
you know that's cool
i and it seemed to me wow what a i said
wow what a what a viable candidate
that's interesting and i remember seeing
some polling
and you were at like two percent and i
said oh that's kind of weird that's not
a very big number at all
i was kind of surprised and then maybe
that was early on but at some point i
you know you were on rogan again or i
saw you in a debate or something
and i and i remember thinking oh i'm
going to check that out again
she's got to be at 30 or 40 now because
i
the people that i know are kind of
talking about her and i'd look and you'd
be at 2
and i was kind of it was very strange to
me that you couldn't get you
you weren't getting any traction
was that weird to you because i mean you
did the whole hawaii thing where you
were
at 2 and then you went to 20 and then
you won by 22. and here you are at 2
you're like that no factor i got this
been here done that yeah
at what point did you say oh damn this
is a little harder than i thought it was
going to be
and was that the same realization as oh
the media doesn't the media and the news
and the entertainment
networks don't care about this stuff
the way i do there
there were different signs of that
the first of which started on the very
day that i announced
officially announced my candidacy as in
build the event go up on the stage
deliver the speech
announcing my candidacy and why and i i
talked about the very thing that we
talked about as as where did you
drive in hawaii what was it uh what
where
outside yeah it was it was outside
at uh in in waikiki
and uh you know there were
local and national media cameras there
to cover it
and uh you know a bunch of supporters
and people came
out while i was giving the speech
nbc news put out an article
uh basically making the accusation that
i am i am somehow a favorite of the
russians or being helped by the russians
uh they're talking they're saying nice
things i
it you know it was the article was so
vague and baseless and lacking in any
kind of evidence to back up the claim
that they were making that
it was just it was just so out there and
and i i
knew that they were doing an article
because they had called and asked for a
comment like a few days prior
and had said you know without knowing
the extent of like the
the completeness of the article but they
said hey you know what i
what do you think about this and um and
and
they had said okay yeah we're going to
publish the article probably sometime
next week maybe wednesday or thursday
and i think i think that my announcement
was on a saturday
whatever day it was they changed their
schedule
for when they were going to publish the
article so that it came out on the day
that they knew i'd be announcing
my candidacy and
and their thing is like the russians
like
tulsi that's the that's the general and
you know like russian bots or like
you know russian state-sponsored media
the thing was
is you know i think they they um said oh
you know there are a lot of
uh articles that are proving that the
russians like her something like that
but when you actually go and look at
look at the articles they're citing
it's it's not accurate first of all
and second of all it lacks the context
of
like hey um they're actually just
reporting that she's announced that
she's running for president
or lacks the context of
well when hillary and obama ran against
each other in 2008
the russian media reported much more
favorably for obama than hillary
and so they they chose a narrative
and chose to launch it on day one of my
candidacy
that tulsi would be the the russian
asset or the favorite
of the russians and planted that seed on
day one
um you know cited oh you know she's
gotten donations from
her campaign from people who
favor russia and you know one happened
to be like a
ivy league professor and specializes in
foreign policy and has
talked about nuclear war for decades and
you know one was a woman who
was trying to promote you know diplomacy
and actually building relationships
between
um like at a grassroots level between
american educators and russian educators
or business owners or whatever i mean
the the the it was just a
it was preposterous and very transparent
a transparent signal and move on day one
so that
yes when did it start that's when it
started and then of course it it
continued to progress and escalate and i
started to see both on the debate stage
as the debate started to begin
as well as um you know
you know you and i talked earlier when
you know you know when you're going in
to do an interview like a media hit
it's probably going to be four to five
minutes long and
you know you go in there knowing what
you want to talk about regardless of the
question that they ask you because
you know you got like you know two
senses
exactly and so this this was why i was
running for president so i took
every opportunity to raise it on every
platform possible
and there were no follow-ups there was
there was no like oh hey like
let's dig deeper into this issue which
is clearly very serious
no none of that it was like well
you know what do you think about this
canada what do you think about trump or
what do you think about this
like superficial drama
um and a conscious choice uh
away from actually talking about uh what
mattered most and it
you know hillary clinton uh weighed in
on the thing
when when she said that um
i forget the exact words but basically
the russians have chosen their candidate
and uh without saying my name said it
was me
and that was then covered by the media
incessantly
which is like crazy it is
it is and it was a signal in and of
itself
like why would why would the former
secretary of state former presidential
candidate former u.s senator former
first lady
go out of her way to place the target
on me and why can't the russian bots do
better than two percent
distraction in the colts if the russian
bots are so freaking powerful
why can't they run up your numbers a
little bit for yeah
yeah not not so much but it it
eventually got to the point
where um not like the coverage that i
got ended up largely being
negative attempts to smear my candidacy
or question my patriotism
and my loyalties so out of the gate
i mean is this is this a grand
conspiracy where they're like oh yeah
tulsi she went against hillary in 2016.
get ready we're putting her down
i certainly appeared that way and on top
of that hey tulsi
she's we can't control her this isn't
gonna work we don't want someone that we
can't control
put her down
it certainly appeared that way because
um that was
if you look at the outcome
it was the outcome that that i think
they were looking for
and again it started from the beginning
it ended up with a total
total media blackout by the end of it
um polling standards
changed to make it so that uh you know
it's like okay here
they say hey you got to pull at a
certain level in order to qualify for
the debate
and then qualify for the next debate and
you know the polling standards often
shifted
based on where you were right like
that's that's a little convenient
to change it right when i start inching
up in the polls a little bit more but
it also just points to like the catch-22
that exists where
in america we'd like to believe that
anybody can run for president
anybody can run for office and that it's
up to the candidate to go and make your
case to voters and voters actually get
to decide well
in these presidential races so early on
you can have very well-known candidates
that everybody in the country's heard of
and you can have lesser known candidates
that most people have
like no knowledge of whatsoever well
they start running these polls
so early on that uh show a lesser-known
candidate like myself
at one percent or two percent whereas
the better known candidates are pulling
much higher and then make the
determination well
tulsi gabbard's not a viable candidate
because she's only pulling at two
percent so we're not going to really
cover her
very much because we don't deem her as a
viable candidate
and by we i mean the media and and the
political party
uh and so as a lesser known candidate
then you're not covered as much as the
better known candidate so you don't have
the opportunity to get better
known and and so it's this you know
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah of we know
who this person is we're going to keep
covering up
and it allows them to um it allows them
to
decide who who they want voters to be
exposed to
and uh who they don't believe deserves
that kind of opportunity to be in front
of voters and so it's kind of a
pre-selection a pre-primary selection
before
before any vote is cast
you have these very powerful people
within the party and within the media
who who make those decisions
about who gets to be heard and and uh
who doesn't
and that that was what we experienced
and it was
it was such an incredible this was the
thing i underestimated the most
that i thought hey i can run for
president i can bring these ideas
forward and yeah i'm at a disadvantage
because i'm not as well known as some of
these other guys but
as long as i have the platform to be
able to reach people
all i got to do is like all i got to do
is do my best and
trust that voters will make will make
the decision i underestimated
how uh very quickly and in a sustained
way the media
the decisions were made to to not even
allow that platform to exist
which left me in a pretty like a pretty
helpless place you know i was
yeah i can live stream my town hall on
social media and i did
i can reach it maybe a few more thousand
people in addition to the thousand who
were sitting in the room
but when you look at the numbers uh in
the country it you know
when when they choose to not cover you
and not allow you that platform
uh then you know it's it's
not only not only was i not able to to
raise the issues and address the issues
that
that are not just important to me but
important to our country
um but also the the smear attempts and
the negative coverage
left me in a very helpless and and
vulnerable position where i
couldn't fight back i did not have
you know did not have the means even if
i were a billionaire
which i'm not and i had a very
very very skinny budget
our art campaign was pretty much fueled
by volunteers and i
love them so much people who really
believed and set aside school or jobs or
life and
when worked their hearts out to help me
get my message out
but even if i were a well-funded
candidate or a self-funded candidate a
billionaire that i could go out and
purchase ads and i could go out and
create
buy my own platform essentially if the
media makes a decision
to either not cover you or
or to smear you and undermine
therefore undermine whatever it is
you're saying and doing
it's it's um
it's difficult if not impossible to beat
and and i think this is so important to
talk about because
it is a charade of the democracy that we
maybe believe exists in this country and
it's certainly a charade of the
democracy that our founders set out
for us in this uh incredible
imbalance of power and influence that's
in the hands of a very few
who don't have the best interests of the
country at heart
so we also got that going for us yeah
and just to illustrate that i mean
this guy who was the ceo of cbs this is
i think probably the most stark and
direct
example uh les moonves is his name
and he this was this was um
yeah i mean this this was in 20 this was
in 2016
that he said uh something along the
lines of
trump may be bad for the country but
he's good for business
the money is rolling in keep it up
donald trump
keep it up and
his very direct statement
illustrates everything that's wrong
because it shows that this corporate
entertainment media it's about the money
it's about the profits
it's about the rating with no regard
whatsoever
for what the consequence is
for the country and for voters and for
our future
and that is
something very serious that we
as people in this country need to
understand and be aware of so that we
can
start to bring about kind of the culture
and societal shifts
that will ultimately result in
um in change and making it so that
you know these few powerful
people don't get to usurp
our democracy and our voices being the
voices that matter
most in determining who we want to serve
as leaders in our country
so with that you see donald trump
getting the
you know getting the nod from the
republicans which many
many many republicans did not want
him to be the candidate at all uh
never trumpers and and so that was a
real thing
they there was a lot of people that a
lot of republicans that did not want
and the republican party was not into
him for much of the primary
exactly like he was totally um and
actually somebody
when we were on uh rogan's together and
i said something like wow you got really
hammered more than i've seen anyone and
someone in the youtube comments said
hey idiot what about donald trump i was
like that's a good point
they hated him apparently as much as
they hated you in the democratic party
how is it that he was able to pull it
off does it is the republican party
less controlling than the democratic
party
i don't know the answer to that specific
question but
how is he able to pull it off
he was very famous and he had influence
they couldn't black him out they
couldn't ignore him
and they were making a [ __ ] ton of money
off of him because
with donald trump brought eyeballs to
their screens
whether it was uh fox news who was
initially i think maybe cynical or even
critical of him and then shifted to like
full bore
pro-trump or if it was cnn and msnbc who
were
i think initially kind of like how is
this even
happening to full-bore anti-trump um
regardless in in all of these scenarios
and
from the democratic party's perspective
and the republican party's perspective
with trump came money
democrats get to be the anti-trump party
and motivate a lot of people
to give money to beat trump or people
who supported trump and
members of congress or whatever and
republicans got to raise a lot of money
off of hey look they're trying to attack
us and they're trying to undermine what
is going on and we need your money and
we need your help to be able to
you know defend the party and defend the
work or whatever it is
so um that
how i think that that's what ultimately
ended up i mean it gave trump a lot of
exposure
and yeah some some of it or maybe a lot
of it was was was uh
was negative but you look at how
much the public hates politicians and
how much
they distrust and hate the media you
know you can kind of see
how generally people who are
frustrated and dissatisfied with the
powerful elite whether they be in
politics or the media
would look at a guy and i have friends
like this like they didn't really agree
with anything that trump was saying
they're like
finally somebody is giving the middle
finger to the media and telling him to
you know shut up or whatever it was
um trump had
influence and
uh he was very well known
and could not be ignored
so at some point does somebody come in
to somebody come from the outside
that's not as brash and not as offensive
as trump
and would that not be a pretty
would that not be easier or was it
because he's so brash
uh and because he's so freaking quotable
right good or bad you know he's just
gonna run they're gonna put
they're gonna put his quotes up all day
long if somebody comes along that's from
the outside but that is actually
less brash and more calm and more
rational
do they say okay it seems like that
would be
the perfect candidate right now someone
from the outside that can actually roll
in and
say look this system is totally screwed
up
we're gonna like the the idea of
draining the swamp
was a great quote that's got so many
legs
or so much legs and it you know of
course it didn't really happen when you
looked at his administration it was like
oh
yeah more people from the swamp more
love yeah exactly
right but but when someone does this in
a more
from a better from a better um
like from a better position it seems
like it's
this is what i'm getting at because i
was going to ask you well at some point
does it reach a tipping point it seems
like the tipping point's there it's just
someone needs to step in and say okay we
are going to actually drain out this
swamp we're gonna actually get rid of
this these lobbies are gonna get you
know
controls put on them we're gonna we're
gonna do things that's gonna move this
in the right direction it seems like
as you said americans a lot of americans
aren't looking at the political system
going you got to be kidding me and look
you telling me stories earlier today
before we hit record
it's kind of it's sickening it is it's
sickening and so
as that word gets out it seems like
america's ready to go you know what
we're done with this [ __ ] over here
and trump was like the first guy that
said hey i'll i'll help you out
and so everyone went cool sounds good
you go raise hell
basically yeah if someone that says yep
we're going to fix it we're going to
change it
i'm for change i'm going gonna make
things it seems like we are right for
that i was good that's what i'm saying
i'm saying
i was going to ask you will we reach a
tipping point it seems like we're
already there
trump was the guy that got elected based
on saying
hey we're going to drain the swamp
people voted for him to go and do that
like you said people that you that you
knew that didn't agree with any of his
politics but he was
changed he was different he was gonna
throw it in the face of the system
that's what we were ready for and it
just so happens that the guy that
threw it in the face of the system also
threw in the face of everybody that was
around him
i mean just like a a grenade going off
it's just people are getting hit
and there's no direction to it so it
seems like we're actually
ready for that
what's it gonna take to actually get
someone there that's gonna run that's
gonna
that that's that that the truth will
come out doing the right things for the
right reasons is gonna win in the end
someone who has the
resources and ammunition capable of
going to battle
with the existing political
infrastructure and the corporate
entertainment media
that that's that's the match up because
i agree
you know there are there are more people
who identify as independents in the
country
today than there are who people who
identify as either democrats or
republicans
really yes factually factually echo
charles are we good to use that word
yes sir thanks that's factually true
we can look up i mean i've seen uh
a variety and this has been trending in
this direction for quite some time this
is not a new phenomena
but the numbers are consistently
trending towards
and and maybe some some of it's
generational that that you know the
millennial generation
did not come up identifying like my
daddy was a democrat my granddaddy was a
democrat i got to be a democrat i think
there's there's
less far less of that in in the
millennial
and post-millennial generation so i
think that's part of it people are
looking more at issues than party
i think part of it is is people
recognizing and being disillusioned with
with both political parties as not
looking out for their best interests
that it's more about the party than the
people so i think there's a number of
reasons for this but it is a fact that
it's over 40 percent of the country
identify themselves as independent and
therefore lesser numbers who identify as
one party another so are the people
ready for
a strong leader who will come in and
speak to what's in the best interest of
the country rather than what's in the
best interest of one party or another i
i would say yes without a doubt
so then the next question is how
what is necessary to execute on that
what is necessary is is first of all
recognizing
you know where's the opposition coming
from
the opposition will come from the people
who are benefiting off the status quo
and that is the existing two-party
system and
the the um the the the entertainment
media that
that is in bed with them
and it's not impossible it's not
insurmountable
but it's a pretty serious obstacle and
you got to be ready
to go to battle with some of the most
powerful people
and uh so
it would take a lot it would take a lot
and the third party thing is what do you
think is that is that dead on arrival
not dead on arrival not impossible very
difficult
because i think it was it was
back and i forget i think was the first
time that ross perot
ran for president uh was also when bill
clinton was running for president
and i think george h.w if i'm not
mistaken yeah i think you're right
at a certain point well early on though
early on at a certain point
ross perot was polling higher than bill
clinton and i
i believe george bush as well and that
like they're like what is going like how
is this possible
and had he continued his campaign at a
certain point ross perot dropped out of
the race
and then jumped back in a little bit
later and he took a big hit for that
i don't know people probably like want
like do you not know what you want
or like what are you doing buddy um but
there are political pundits who say that
if he had continued on
um he you know who knows he may have
become president or he may have
posed a more serious threat in the end
than he did ultimately his numbers
took a dive after he re-entered the race
and he ended up
kind of just being the perennial third
party guy who stole votes right
but it was after that election year that
the rules started to change in making it
uh with with agreement from both the
democrat and republican party
that made it much more difficult
for a third-party candidate to get
ballot access just to get their names
on the ballot
to be included in debates
just the basic infrastructure of
a candidacy um changed to the point
where and it still
it still exists today that the the bar
is much higher for a third-party
candidate
to to be heard and to be on the ballot
than it is
for uh candidates who run under one
party or
or another so that that
that just again not impossible but from
a practical perspective
as well as from a an exposure
perspective
it's a much much much heavier lift
that again requires a certain strategy
and a hell of a lot of resources to be
able to accomplish that
so how long how long were you in the
race for total
um i think i announced in february
of 2019
and i withdrew from the race
i think in march february or march of
i think it was march of uh
2020. it was it was after
kovid had kind of already started i was
back in hawaii
kovid had started to take a pretty firm
hold maybe it was even later than that
and it just it got to the point where
like we're on lockdown
at home in hawaii congress had shut down
and uh i knew that
the most effective use of my time at
like
the outcome of the primary seemed
somewhat inevitable at that point and
the most effective use of my time would
be to focus on how i could best help
with with the response
of covid in hawaii and you know i was
calling trying to get like
n95 masks and just trying to help help
with that local response in hawaii
so you so you what is that called
dropping out of the race is that what
it's called
is there some official word for it yeah
no withdrew my candidates
so you went through suspending that's
the word they use
suspending your candidacy and did you
feel like
what the hell just happened did you feel
like wasted time did you feel like man
because i again i remember looking at
you in the polls
and you know you might have gotten to
three percent or four percent i could i
i was really surprised i was really
surprised
you know that you just didn't get the
kind of traction
again as as joe said
you're like such a kind of ideal
candidate from
like a box checking you're a veteran
you're a woman
you've been you've got experience you've
got combat
deployments you you're uh whatever not a
white person
you got these things that people are
looking for hapa
yeah you're hapa right so so you got
those things
and it just seemed like oh okay it'll be
interesting to watch this she's going to
climb right up this thing
and you never really made that progress
does that surprise you
i mean in hindsight no because you
because you see you
you mess with the machine at that moment
like going through it
um it surprised me that i didn't even
have the opportunity to earn it
to earn the support to get that exposure
i remember you telling me at some point
you were like the number one most
googled name
after the first debate after the second
debate what you didn't make the third
debate for whatever reason
yeah i don't remember which you know i
think there was there was
yeah there was a gap at some point where
i didn't make one but then i made the
the next i don't remember exactly what
but in those first
in those first debates um i was the most
searched candidate of the night
after each of those debates which was
the whole point
you know hey i can go on this stage a
national stage
the first debate i think had over 20
million viewers
and this is the opportunity to introduce
myself to the american people
uh in the hopes that they might say hmm
she looks interesting
i want to know more i want to learn more
and that being starting to kind of crack
open the door to be able to
make an impact there i think
one of the other in addition to all the
things that we talked about about
how that opportunity really ultimately
did not exist and it started with
that first debate um you know in advance
we had set up
our google ads account so that when
people
went on google and said hey who is tulsi
gabbard
then you know our links would pop up and
they would then go to my website and
they could
look at you know click issue x y or z
what do you care about bio background
etc
um that was the hope that that would be
i would be the most googled candidate
and that we therefore were ready for it
um google shut down our google ads
account
with no reason whatsoever at all given
during the first debate it was not
actually during the debate
it was afterward but it was during that
it was during that window of time that
was the golden opportunity
to capture and it was a limited window
and they they just like
your your account is suspended no
explanation no
here's what you got to do to fix it or
get it you know
whatever released and uh and to this day
we've never gotten you know it was
suspended for a certain period of time
and then
it was reinstated and it was not for
lack of us trying to reach
anybody who would answer us and tell us
why and what we could do to fix it
immediately
so you know i mean there's i filed a
lawsuit against google
for that um because of
because of the the impact obviously that
it had on me but also but really the
bigger issue
that i i wanted to raise by filing this
lawsuit was
you've got this massive big tech company
who has the power to um
interfere in the public square of our
democracy
and you know who knows still to this day
like was it some guy sitting at a
computer who was like man [ __ ] tulsi
gabbard i'm gonna
punch this button and show her what's up
or like who knows i don't know
what happened but it happened
and if it can happen to a sitting member
of congress who's running for the
highest office in the land
it could happen to anybody running for
office
anybody who's speaking out anybody being
critical of
whether it's big tech or government
policy whatever the motive
this is the power that they have in
their hands that's incredibly dangerous
in undermining the the kind of core
pillars of of our democracy of
having a marketplace of free ideas and
voters who can
you know get the information they need
and ultimately make the decision
that they want to make
are they allowed to are they allowed to
mess with like google adwords from a
political perspective so
in other words if i was running against
you and i
bought the adword tulsi gabbard and
brought it to a freaking russian
uh newspaper article about how they're
your favorite so when i
google tulsi gabbard i click on the
first article that comes up it shows me
that you're a russian
plant can i do that in the political
realm because look they do it with
like i you know i i have a bunch of
companies and sell a bunch of stuff and
you type in jocko you know the
other companies pay for that word for
jocko protein and it brings
to their site right so if i was a
billionaire
and you were running against me i could
be like oh cool i'll just buy tulsi
gabbard who is telstra gabbard what is
taos of gabbard where's chelsea gabbard
come from and i'll just buy all those
things and send them all to uh
tulsi gabbers from russia or whatever
else i'm gonna do
is that legal in the polit i know it's
illegal in the in the free market
because they do it all the time
is it legal in the political side as far
as i know i
i am not i have not come across any kind
of
like legislation against adwords
in google there there are there are no
laws or rules in place from a government
perspective
that that limit what these big tech
monopolies
can do with their algorithms
and that's part of the whole issue here
when we talk about big
tech the monopolies the power that they
have
to either promote or push forward
certain voices or
people or ideas and silence others
and they can do so while being
completely
legally immune from any kind of
accountability through
our legal system because they're private
companies well
because yeah because they're private
companies but this section 230 provision
that exists within the law
that was was put in place to encourage
innovation on the internet early you
know decades ago
when they passed that law it
that gave them this legal immunity it
said
that they can they can remove
content that they deem to be
objectionable
without any definition of what that is
first of all
whatever they want it to be whatever
they want it to be and then it says
whether or not it is protected
by the constitution dang
how i don't know who wrote that
part of it probably the same bastard
that clicked delete onto your freaking
account
for six hours but to have something in
there that says
you internet you know service provider
company
you can decide what speech you deem
or content objectionable or not whether
or not
it is protected by our constitution
this is the problem that needs to be
fixed within our laws today
as it relates to big tech and it's a
relatively there's
a lot of iv and i've looked at this a
lot while i was in congress and then
after for obvious reasons
and you know there's a lot of different
proposals and different ways to kind of
bite this apple but the most simple and
direct
way would be to take out that
objectionable content just take those
words out
and instead um you know
you can say unless it is unless it you
know you you
can remove content unless it is
protected under the first amendment
and there's legal precedence in place
through various supreme court rulings
that provide very clear
kind of guard rails towards what kind of
speech is protected
versus what is not and that way
if if we make this legislative change it
would alleviate the kind of pressure
that these big
companies are under right now coming
from the left and the right
because then they can just say look
these are the guard rails
this is speech that's protected and it's
going to remain
on the internet and speech that's not
protected then it's up to us to
make that decision to to uh to remove it
that that's that's the that's the best
answer that i have come across
on how to um address this
rather than allowing this you know i
mean now we have like okay well we're
going to cancel anything that's
disinformation we're going to cancel
anything that's misinformation we're
going to
you know cancel anything that um
we don't like or you know i mean it's
getting worse and worse and
unfortunately the direction that i'm
seeing from
democrats in congress is not towards hey
how do we protect free speech
but instead it's we need big tech to do
more to shut people up who are saying
things
that uh we deem to be
misinformation or disinformation or that
could
mislead people into believing a certain
thing
or seeing a certain view and it's it's
it is
you know the the fact that this is
happening and people don't see the
danger of
okay you're in power today you got kevin
mccarthy who's the head of the
republicans in the house saying
i bet my house on the fact that
republicans will regain the majority in
2022. what are you going to do when the
tables turn
and then you've got the other guys in
power saying yeah you know what we don't
want democrats to be
misleading people on the internet so
we're going to tweak the language a
little bit and make sure that big tech
silences those voices and pushes like
it's it's so
simple and clear dangerous of a position
that we are in
and that when you when you threaten
the first amendment like freedom of
speech a free press
like freedom of religion um
once you undermine that what do we have
in america
we don't we don't have we don't have
the country we don't have our country
yeah we did um
we did a podcast and we recorded it
before christmas
but we did it on 1980 the book 1984. i
listened to that
yeah and it was really weird because we
just you know it's just something that i
was like all the same things that are
going on and i
and i you know read that book many many
years ago and i remembered this one part
of it was about the language and
the importance of language and the
therefore the importance of free speech
and we recorded it and then like it was
christmas time and
that that podcast came out january 6th
and it was kind of crazy that it came
out on that day it just we had recorded
it a month prior
and you had scheduled it for that it was
just that's when it's coming out so it
came out january 6th then
1984 was trending and then
the the tat the hashtag 1984
some some hashtag 1984 actually got shut
down
on twitter it was i don't know it was
all it wasn't it wasn't
because of that podcast but it was just
very coincidental
that all that was happening at the same
time but
the point of doing that podcast and this
is exactly aligned with what you're
saying
you have to allow people to communicate
with each other yeah
and you know saying if you if if you say
something to me that's misleading
i can't just it's what i started off
with i just don't say shut up you're not
allowed to talk i say okay well
actually tulsi let me show you some
other information that might change your
mind a little bit
because by the way when i just tell you
to shut up i don't
move your opinion at all in fact
there's a really good chance that i'm
just going to make you even stronger
on that opinion and that's what's
happening in the country right now which
is freaking nasty
and and yeah and actually that again
interestingly as all this was happening
we we had had i talked to echo i was
like listen man
i don't know what's gonna happen in the
world and i don't know what's gonna
happen look
we don't we're not on here making any uh
inflammatory statements we're usually
talking about history i said
and that's cool we'll that's what we're
gonna do but at some point people are
starting to change history and
i said i don't know what's gonna even
happen with the platforms that we're on
yeah like these platforms could change
the way they do business and we
started our own platform just to make
sure that we have
some place to someplace to go
in the event that things take a turn for
the worse and there's a bunch of other
things that could happen i mean
you could have some of these free
platforms say all right we're going to
start charging money
and start inserting ads into the middle
of you know here's jocko talking about a
a battle in world war ii and it's heavy
and crazy and emotional and some
someone's gonna insert an
ad in there like i don't want that i
don't want people to have to
put up with that so i don't know
or do we just get someone to say look
hey jonko you talked about
this part of history which
you know we don't really like we think
it's misinformation and pull it down
that's that's that's a reality that
could happen yeah
so we have to be wha that's why we made
we made the
the jocko underground just because of
that
uh so that's the platform that you guys
created it's the platform yeah
jacounderground.com and it's just a
backup
and look some people are like oh you
want money i was like no we don't want
your money
yeah that's not what it's about but to
not have a contingency plan
is ignorant and so and again all that
what's funny about all this is i had
talked to echo about it he was kind i
said hey can you build something figure
this out he's you know working and
figuring it out and
eventually goes yeah you know i got it i
mean this was before the end of 2020
this is before the end of 2020.
it was a let's have a contingency plan
in case something happened
right and then i said you know what
this is getting squirrely it's getting
squirrely let's
launch the contingency plan you know
next month just to have just to get it
out there so people know what it is in
case something happens
and sure enough january 6th it was like
boom
we had it was so coincidental but it was
very
it was like and i remember texting echo
like well i guess this is why we had a
contingency plan and thank god it
launched today
because who knows where it's going to be
in six months i don't know
i don't know it's crazy
i remember um listening to that
night so i i don't i have not listened
like i have friends of mine who have
listened to your podcast from
number one and then uh those people are
my friends too
yeah but but like in in sequence
like chronologically and like um
a buddy of mine got to the the i think
it was episode 99 as musashi
100 100 well he couldn't get past 99
because he didn't finish reading the
book
and i'm like hey jocko just did this new
show on i can't do it because i can't
listen to 100 until i read the book so
check yeah spoiled
so i'm not one of those people i'll jump
around you've missed episodes
echo is disappointing i'll jump around
like okay what am i in the mood like
what am i in the mood for
wait am i in the mood for dark
depressing war am i in the mood for
human atrocity where am i at and i'll
tell you a funny story about that in a
second
but um i went straight
for that 1984 and i don't remember what
actual day it was
it was not january 6 but it was in in
the days after and i
i wondered then if when you had recorded
that
because it was literally addressing
everything
that we were seeing play out right right
before us
as far as the warning signs and the
dangers of this is where
this is where you end up uh once you
allow for this kind of
control and once we as people
accept it um
but a little sidetrack funny story and
i'll show you the video after
um because it'll take me a minute to dig
it up but
it won't surprise you to know that on
the presidential campaign trail sleep
was hard to come by for me
and for two reasons one was just a
factor of time
in the day but also it was tough for me
to um tough for me to turn
turn everything off and actually just
get like i'm not even talking about
hours i'm just talking about just some a
good
a slice of good quality rest and sleep
we were in new hampshire in the middle
of winter and there was a rare
opportunity where i
got to take a nap and we'd like rented a
like an airbnb or something like that
and so i took a nap and my husband took
a video
of me taking a nap because he walked in
the room
and i'm i'm lying there and i'm asleep
and i'm all bundled up under the covers
and i got my phone sitting on my um
on the top of the covers and i was
listening to
jocko podcast with a guy from the french
foreign legion
[Music]
and i'll show you the video because i am
dead asleep and uh my husband came in
and he
has the camera going picks up my phone
looks at
and the reason i remember this was
because this was on february 11th
february 11th 2020 and it just so
happened
that it popped up on my phone on
february 11th of this year
as like the memory thing or whatever and
i was debating sending it to you
and i told my husband i was like oh he
doesn't get the wrong idea and think i'm
like
bored to death on this podcast and he's
like no what it showed was
like i was able to completely tune out
the noise of of what was going on in my
mind of the day to day
and and be able to kind of be
transported to a different
conversation and topic and and all this
other stuff but
it was a great podcast that i did end up
finishing
but you gave me the gift of some really
good sleep as well the soothing the
soothing voice of choco talking about
war can send anyone to sleep i don't
know what that says about me
and what makes me relax
anyhow i remember when uh when you
dropped out of the race
and you you um
endorsed biden yeah and i remember
thinking because again
i didn't know a lot of these things that
you're telling me right now i knew them
kind of but i still
i i still had a some sort of naive sense
in my heart that it can't be that bad
and i remember i texted you and i said
like hey are you gonna get the vp
naught is this cause i was i was kind of
surprised you endorsed biden i was like
well you know what oh
i said oh i know what's happening she's
playing the game she's going to endorse
biden bind's going to get her as the vp
it's on and you were like you like you
like
however you laugh and text you're like
hey hey bro you're a little bit uh
you're a little bit lost there oh
and then so so then you wrapped up your
your career well you wrapped up this
portion of your career as a politician
in in that was it went out to dc for the
last congressional
session yeah packed up your locker
january 2nd was my last official day
we had to pack up the office before
thanksgiving
so uh no kidding you know we were there
were obviously votes going into december
there was uh
you know government's gonna shut down if
we don't pass a new appropriations bill
and kind of the unfortunate usual thing
that happens at the end of every year
um but yeah i was working out of my car
like parked in front of the capitol i
had my computer and
it's covered so you know votes consist
of
seven different groups of members of
congress i was group two it's
by alphabetical order where you're only
allowed to have a certain number of
people on the floor at any given time
they decontaminate the whole floor
between every vote
and so when your group is called you go
in cash your vote and then you leave
and so that was like a park my votes are
called sometimes they last for
you know an hour or two hours or
whatever and if you've got four votes in
a series then
you're doing this running in and out you
know four times
in that series and so yeah i was you
know office office shut down before
thanksgiving had to turn in everything
so that they could um transition and
start to bring in
other members of congress and i should
mention now that that um
i made the decision not to run for
re-election to my house seat
in october of
2019 when
it it got to the point where i had to
make a decision where
i would either continue my candidacy or
i would suspend my presidential campaign
and focus on running for reelection in
hawaii and
i couldn't do both legally i could have
but just the constraints of
of time and the tyranny of distance it
was not
i was i would end up doing a crappy job
at both so
that was the decision i made i i you
know let folks and i wanted people in
hawaii to know that
um you know they were not some kind of
fallback plan for me if this national
thing didn't work out and that
they would have the opportunity and the
time to decide who they would want
you know to to work for them and other
candidates who who um
who are going to run so and that was a
decision i never looked back on
um or regretted in any way but as a
result of that yeah so
i think things started quickly and
having to shut down in dc
but january 2nd was was the actual final
day
were you um heading home kind of stoked
that it was over or were you heading
home kind of bummed out
that it was over mixed feelings really
mixed feelings
um again i made that decision without
regret and so it wasn't
any surprise that this was going to
happen at this point in time
but i mean i remember landing at dulles
airport
and on that last trip and as i was
driving into dc
like i'm not gonna make this drive again
as a member of congress at least
and uh even as
screwed up as things are and as
frustrating as things are and have
progressively gotten
it never takes away the awesomeness
of that privilege of being able to serve
uh in that in that way and you know
there are grooves have you have you been
inside the state capital the the
the capital before the us capital when
you go inside
there are you know uh
marble steps that take you up to the the
actual entrance to the house floors on
the second floor and then the visitors
galleries on the third floor
when you walk those steps there are
they're deeply worn grooves
where countless other leaders from our
nation's history have walked those
very steps and the
the um it's an amazing thing
to to never forget
those who have come before us those who
will come after
and how special of a privilege it is
that
the people of hawaii allowed me that
privilege to to do my best to serve them
for the eight years uh that i was there
and that was
that was you know yeah i there's so much
of the political
drama and and just the theatrics and the
all of the stuff that you just kind of
gotta endure
in order to try to do the work that
you're trying to do and
and i i've always hated all that stuff
and had no
no problem at all leaving that uh that
behind
but i think the the the mixed feelings
and emotions part just came from
um just that that reflecting on the time
that i've had there and honestly wishing
that there are a lot of areas and things
that i wish i could have done more on
that i could have
you know um legislation that i wished
had been able to advance farther
or it's just different things you know
assessing kind of
what i was able to do what i wished i
was able to do and
um but but leaving with the sense of
of peace uh in my heart
in in knowing that you know i i did my
best
and excited about how i can find
uh how i will find a way to continue to
serve
so you get back home to hawaii
and i know when i came back from my last
deployment to iraq
i had um i was home for
i was home for like a month and one day
i just like woke up on a saturday and i
kind of felt like
this weird weight
i i felt good right i felt good and i
felt
like the weight was gone and i was kind
of thinking about what what
wha why do i feel so good right now and
i realized oh
it's because i'm not worried about one
of my guys getting wounded or killed
right now because we're home from
deployment and it took me about a month
for that to go away because it's just
your instinct every time every time you
wake up
you you're thinking about what's
happening is is everyone okay you're
thinking about that all the time and i
never noticed it when i was on
deployment because that's just how it
was it was just you know you just wake
up and that's what you're thinking and
it's real
well after a month of waking up and oh
no it's not you don't have to worry
about that oh oh no you don't have to
worry about that and eventually one day
i woke up and said why don't i feel
oh it's because i'm not worried about
that thing i've been worried about for
so long when you got home i mean the
how long did it take for that to wear
off the pressure the
the constantly thinking about all this
crap that's going on and what you need
to do and where you need to move and
what's the next maneuver and who's mad
at you and who's happy with you and all
this other crap
how long did it take you for for you
like oh i hope i have oh wait
do i have wax for my surfboard right now
how long did that take not very long
you were able to get i was ready man
but it also you know i mean just this
whole covid situation also
um you know i i had been home a lot more
than i normally would have been and
working from home and having virtual
committee hearings and a lot of other
stuff that
was just it was a strange lead-up
to where the contrast wasn't so
different
um but it was it was odd for me like it
started
august is when our primary elections are
in hawaii and i remember waking up on
primary election day which is saturday
in hawaii
and i was like oh my gosh i'm don't have
to go sign waving at
six o'clock in the morning um i can
i can go surfing like this is a weird
feeling because i had held elected
office for
the previous 10 years i'd been on a
ballot every single election for the
previous 10 years
and so that was that was strange that
was a really weird thing that was
felt unnatural uh to me and then
and then you know similarly um with the
general election
but yeah i was um i had no
issue with that transition and
and yeah went on to to uh take full
advantage of
of being home and
knowing that well really a lot of it was
being able to regain control over
how i spent my time and
have to to to no longer have those
very immediate political factors playing
into decisions that i'm making
and um just to
just to be for the first time in a long
time
not have not been constantly jet-lagged
that was something i
didn't realize took such a toll for
eight years i'm going back and forth two
or three times a month between hawaii
and dc
five or six hours difference every time
plane rides are long but that was not an
ass
whatever i can it's a plane ride um
but you know like like i can actually
like
get a schedule happening and stick with
it and not be up at
two o'clock in the morning because it's
eight in dc and then
you know go to sleep at six cause it's
midnight like it's just you know it was
just
just basic like simple life things like
i
i like to cook like i could act like hey
like i'm like i can go grocery shopping
and cooking and not have to worry like
is the food gonna rot by the time i have
to leave and then come back it's just
like simple little things um it was it's
it's nice so let's get into what you're
settling into now
the dust is settled and you're
able to buy groceries cook them before
they rot
you're able to surf yeah train
get on a schedule but obviously
that's not what you're going to do for
the rest of your life yeah what else is
going on what else you got going on
in the world so i am uh so i'm still
serving in the army reserves i have i
moved from the national guard to the
reserves
and uh transitioned my branch
to civil affairs awesome which
um is often called kind of the
the warrior diplomat service
and um yeah it's it's
fantastic it's been a great move and
one that's focused on building
relationships
and uh it's kind of kind of right at my
eyes something i've been interested for
a really long time that that i never
pursued because it doesn't exist within
the national guard for obvious reasons
the national guard focuses domestic
mission first
but civil affairs is 98 of civil affairs
forces
in the united states army live within
the army reserves
there's the remaining whatever two
percent
is um basically lives on
on fort bragg as part of the the
unconventional um
special forces community and so uh
yeah i i'm appreciating the training the
experience
and also some of the missions that i've
already been able to serve on there
um i as as kind of a direct result
of everything that we talked about with
my experience
with the the mainstream media and
being filtered into you know or limited
to sound bites
their unwillingness to go in depth or
even really cover any
real issues serious issues and just the
caricatures that they
they create um i am launching my own
show where i will have the opportunity
to um
really speak uh directly to people
in an unfiltered way and an unlimited
way
um both both about a lot of you know
some of these issues that we've talked
about and have conversations with people
who can shed light and bring their
expertise or experience on them
but also just be able to
have a platform where
i can take some of those experiences
that i've had and i'm sure you've had
the same because i've seen it in the
military i've seen it in politics where
whether it's traveling to different
parts of the country or traveling to
different parts of the world
there's there's so much
more that we have in common as people
than um is often focused on or that we
even we may
realize and so i look forward to being
able to to have that platform my show is
called this is tulsi gabbard just
because it is just me um and
and use that as as a an opportunity to
be able to
fill that gap or or to
provide what uh the mainstream media and
the corporate media
is not offering uh to to people and and
that i found there's there is there's a
lot of hunger for that for real
conversation whether it's with people
you agree with or
or to have a dialogue you know i want to
be able to have people on my show who
represent
different views on an issue and who are
interested in having a respectful
conversation about it and why you hold
one view why do you hold the other view
where is their common ground where is
their irretractable differences
where where do you draw the line and and
i think
being able to um
provide this platform i hope will result
in
more people thinking like hey maybe i
can start talking to my neighbor who
voted for the other guy or the other
party and we haven't really talked for
like a year because of it but
maybe we should just like start the
conversation and see where it goes and
that it's okay
and that we in america should be
encouraging
civil discourse and dialogue and
um encouraging when we talk about what
we have to protect freedom of speech
what does that mean well you know and
how do you do it
like let's start with um
speaking sharing our ideas and
not as you started this whole our
conversation today
not in a way that says i'm right you're
wrong
i have to be heard you don't get to be
heard
but in a way that that um that we don't
see now where if you believe in
something you hold a view
that you feel is important strong and
communicate that
also recognize that not everyone may
share that view
for whatever reason maybe they have a
different background a different
experience and
one that you may not have and that the
more we can encourage this kind of
exchange
the stronger we are as a society that we
don't lose
by having uh
great platforms for people to share them
and that that's the biggest difference
between
what we're seeing today versus what i
believe our founders envisioned for us
where somehow
we've come to a place where the powerful
people in this country
think that it's it's really a sign of
insecurity
where if those who hold different views
are allowed to air them then somehow
you'll lose which means
maybe you're not confident yeah that
what you're offering is going to quote
unquote win
or convince people that it is a superior
idea
yep it's it's so it it plays out
leadership strategy and tactics i
talk about this you know if you if i'm
in charge and tulsi you say
hey hey jonko i don't think we should do
it like that and my response is shut up
and do what i told you to do
i don't look strong no i look weak yeah
i look weak
if i say well tulsi how do you think we
should do it and i listened to your idea
and i incorporate some of your idea
into the overall plan because you were
able to convince me because you had a
different perspective than i did you'll
see you'll look at me and think oh i
really like working with
working for jocko i really like working
with
jocko because he's listening to what i'm
saying and all of a sudden we're coming
up with actual better solutions by the
way
it's not like it's oh i'm doing this to
appease to appease tulsi right now so
she'll
you know work harder for me no she's
actually got a presentation to me that
actually makes more sense we're gonna
use it
yeah so we're trying to get somewhere so
this is a podcast your new your new
show yeah it'll be uh you know available
on all the podcast platforms
[Music]
we're also doing video it so i
i i um so i i talked to you some time
ago and asked some questions about how
you launch a podcast and such
and um one of the things you told me
about was consistency is key
both of you that's that's uncontrolled
well the message was received and so
what i'm doing is so
so soon within within the next few weeks
but
i'm recording a number of shows to have
in the bank to make sure that you know
hey i got to go away to training for a
couple of weeks that
we're not gonna we're not gonna um skip
a beat
so how long is the show have you
recorded somewhere i have yeah
uh you know i there no no real time
limit but right now they're about not
like an hour and a half
ish you're not going jocko psycho four
hours
i'm not opposed to it but no no no rules
no rules and i i think that's that's
the cool thing about it so is that the
main focus of your effort training right
now it is
yeah you're gonna launch this show and
uh
i think probably by the end of this
month is what i'm aiming for
awesome so where can people find you uh
people can find uh
me at tulsi gabbard on all the social
media platforms
um and also on my website uh tulsi
gabbard.com
there's there's a few different things
that that i'm looking to do there
updates and and information and i've
i've moved it away from what it was
traditionally which is a political
campaign website and and really focusing
more
on how we can um
build communities and conversation uh in
our
in our society i don't care if you're
democrat republican independent i don't
care if you voted for trump or voted for
hillary or
whatever none of that should matter as
we come together to to um
rebuild bridges focused on how we
collectively as americans can
work together for the future of our
country
legit
charles yes um that seems like a good
place to wrap
this this session i don't know maybe
this
a good place to wrap up this session
sure
tulsi's obviously been charging hard for
well since you were
16 years old as a water woman
which again we will be certain we will
be scouring the internet for that she's
been on the path
echo charles and i'm thinking we should
be on the path too
what suggestions do you have do i have
hey when you go to the grocery store do
people like stop you a lot still
in hawaii definitely oh yeah they do
that foodland which is interesting
because
and i say i know you you're water woman
i don't know where those kids are now
hey billy how you doing i remember you
where's your cape yeah exactly
it's still there it's the same town
yeah on on kauai like when you'd see the
mayor yeah at wherever you know
star market for sure um yeah you'd
always stop and be like hey you know so
i would imagine if someone had like some
thing you know something they want to
address they they wouldn't hesitate to
stop you because you're right there
it happened most recently um i was out
surfing
the reef near the mokulua islands and
the east side of
oahu and the surf there only goes off
like it's only really good when there's
no wind
and there's swell obviously and it's
it's a long it's it's like
three quarters of a mile paddle from
shore out there
uh but it happened most recently there
like usually it's like
someone will paddle up be like where do
i know you from
and then and then like one as an
advantage like oh yeah hi i'm tulsa oh
my god that's what i thought and then
word in the lineup travels pretty
quickly and the last time i was
a couple of weeks ago the waves were
really stayed out for four hours and
um people just like hey tulsi
guys on stand-up boards looking down at
me on my surfboard and
talking stories like oh what this
whatever it's so it's it's cool
i like it yeah imagine so
you go to sandy beach um i have been i
generally stay away from i don't want to
threaten like my life by
body searching at sandy's short break
do you uh yeah bowser that was our spot
yeah for sure but back in the day
back in the day all right how are we
staying on the path
okay all right all right we're working
out we're surfing yeah
snowboarding zombo are you a snowboarder
i ski snowboard but echo charles has
recently become
highly engaged in snowboard shredding
oh i like it it's true but we are
working out
and training for various things
so i was pretty stoked when you were
running and you put like um
whatever videos of you doing squats yeah
and i'm like come on
go did we get a couple percentage points
of
increase on just doing burpees
i was giving credit i was like yeah i
kind of you know i'm leaning in your
direction just see you do a burpee
that's all good in the polls yeah
watching that saying oh there's tulsi
doing burpees hey let's at least throw a
dog
right come on let me earn it with some
burpees
it's freaking ridiculous yeah i didn't
really see much
uh burpees by joe biden or anything i
didn't see yeah i didn't see joe biden
doing any burpees
nobody else nobody really else kind of
got on the
the fitness kick yeah crazy
all good nonetheless we're going to stay
on the path over here so through the
path
we may need supplementation i would
suggest supplementation don't worry
chocolate
i believe in that it's true yeah true
story 100
so here you go you got joints that need
attention
sometimes especially when we get older
we're not
eating younger is this the collective
week as far as okay
because i know i'm not yeah i vote
against it stay in the same age i get it
but for those of us who are you know we
want to get something that helps in the
routine
supplementation for joints protein
brain body all this stuff so what do we
got joint warfare
joints krill oil joints discipline and
discipline go
brain and body how's that discipline
going
this this is good i i this is the first
time i'm trying the the discipline go
jocko palmer
drink very good tasty very good no sugar
in that
yeah see i use monk fruit
like in my protein shakes and stuff like
what's up yeah man too sweet didn't it
to sweeten it yeah because you get you
get you get the good
natural like healthy sweetener without
like
the carbs of like maple syrup for
example guess who just made the
the clip of the wheat oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's my girl
tulsa which maple syrup is my
my go like i would only eat pancakes to
have maple syrup really
but you know i can't did you get any
maple syrup from pete up in
up in maine no pete come on man
yeah he's out there and he used to do it
himself
but now you know it's just like friends
and and it's real maple syrup you can go
up there oh man
that was and sorry echo i'm messing with
your jam here man but
it's your jam one of the coolest
experiences well there were many but one
of the coolest was when i stopped in
freedom new hampshire
and went to a sugar shack met with
the three generations of family who have
passed down
from you know father to child
uh and got to see the whole thing we
went up to the trees
saw the taps came down saw the whole
process
and then of course like sampled the
goods
i'm like maple syrup is it ever since
i've been a kid like those little maple
leaf candies and
you're just done finished i was up in
maine talking to pete and he's
like a sugar addict he obviously can't
eat it that's why
but he he was saying he would take
little um
a pencil box you know the pencil box you
had when you were a little kid
he would fill that with sugar cubes and
hide it underneath his bed
and at night when he'd go to bed he put
like a little crack at it
he started like going into a different
realm mentally
and he goes he goes bro have you ever
tried have you ever eaten sugar
he's talking to me about yeah like crazy
you were when were you you were talking
about that right on like um
a thing yeah one of the origin videos
came out you showed me talking about
that
yes so it did sound crazy the way you
were talking about but then i remember
like we didn't just buy sugar cubes but
every once in a while like you'd get the
little pack right with all the sugar
cubes and it
and i'd eat those two they're like
little candies
yeah but it's like pure it's like main
lining the sugar it's
kind of good i i didn't hide them on my
bed
stealing those things from your own
family
and putting them in it's like a little
psycho right that's different you know
well monk fruit yeah no sugar yeah
exactly that's not sugar monk fruit is
good stuff it's
natural and by the way we went the
distance and i held out long the other
thing that's
cool about this drink is which was
really hard to do
is the way that you make it stay good on
the shelf
is it has to you have to preserve it
somehow and what
companies normally do is they just add
chemicals to it right and they're called
preservatives we've all heard of that
right
yes well instead of using preservatives
which i didn't want to do
it's it's pasteurized so it's like
cooked so there's no but there's no
chemicals in it but it costs us a ton of
money to get it going
and it took us an extra almost it took
us
over six months to get this all set up
but then we did it now you can drink
this and your kids can drink it
my own kids can drink my drink it's
something that my
my mom always encouraged us and it's
like a habit i got into from a young age
like just read the ingredients before
you buy it
and if you don't understand half of the
things that are on the ingredients
then you know think twice about
you know putting it in your body let me
ask you if you understand these
ingredients
filtered carbonated water natural flavor
citric acid monk fruit
that's the ingredient list done and it
has the
vitamin b6 and b12 like it's got the
other positive things right the actual
the
the food ingredients that's it that's
incredible
and more people are becoming conscious
of this these days for sure really i
mean more people are becoming aware
and whether it's because of health like
diabetes and or whatever else
but i think there's just an increased
level of awareness of like hey
and and even more so with covid like i
really should be healthy i should
strengthen my immune system and i should
know what i'm consuming i felt so bad
the last time you visited so
whatever three months ago something like
that you came by we didn't have time to
record
i didn't have time to record or whatever
but you just came by to hang out a
little bit
and whatever two days later i called you
up and said
hey hey or i sent you a text hey how you
doing you're like fine i'm like got
something to tell you
you're like what i'm like i got covered
luckily i only saw like 10 people yeah
in that
time period of whatever that week was
where i knew i had
well i had been uh tested positive for
covet
texted echo he's like yeah i can't smell
anything
this is a bummer dude
i felt bad about that but um it happens
unfortunately
yeah but um yeah so there you go
yeah you talk about the immunity thing
yeah so come to find out giaco has that
covered as well as far as
supplementation goes vitamin d3
helps with immunity and a special
supplement called cold war it was
again this was crazy right like so i
before covered i traveled all the time
on planes on you know all the time and
you know the nightmare of that and
you're breathing in everyone's stuff
and so i said you know what i'm gonna
make you know a good
immunity booster with a bunch of vitamin
c and just things that
and so i made it and cool and it was
selling good and whatever
but then covet hit yeah and the tooth
and
i also made vitamin d already made it
this isn't like oh
it's it's covered it was already in the
system it was already it was already
live because i only i take vitamin d
and boom as soon as covet hit it was
like we could we had to just
we we sold out almost immediately and
then we just had to ramp it up but
luckily we had already had the formulas
built so
that stuff is awesome cold war and then
and the vitamin d3
that's true all good for you i'm a
supplement taker just in general but i
was not taking vitamin d
prior to covid nor was i really aware of
how important
it was until i started to learn and read
more and see especially related to covid
how most americans are deficient
like vast majority of americans are
deficient in vitamin d
and especially people who have any kind
of
you know colored tone to their skin even
more so
um are found to be deficient in vitamin
d so
uh i am now a daily consumer
well vitamin d yeah yeah i learned that
when we had our
daughter where everything you know you
read for best development all this stuff
vitamin d was always popping up
with everything oh yeah vitamin vitamin
d that's true
but yeah so yeah got some get some
vitamin d also don't forget about milk
this is extra protein in the form of a
dessert
yeah by the way sometimes it's just
dessert that has protein straight up
yeah especially if you get your little
formula down like some people they just
go milk milk milk
almond milk whatever cool good but some
of us we
we have our perfectly tuned formula yeah
half a spoon of peanut butter one scoop
mint chocolate one scoop peanut butter
chocolate
one banana damn wow give milk or two
percent milk boom
that's the formula in my household i
randomly tried almond milk
with peanut butter milk
bro yeah legitimate what is up
that's a freaking milkshake yeah that's
a milkshake
so that i added a banana like
reluctantly
like i was like okay banana because
sometimes banana can jam up your whole
flavor profile
let me ask you this are they frozen or
fresh
both whatever because okay and then
because the result is a little bit
different
it's possible i'm not that advanced to
tell the difference and here dude here's
why i know about the frozen banana when
a banana is starting to get
uh rotten a little bit pass right
because the brown is taking over
you can peel it and freeze it that's
what i do yes i didn't know that
sarah told me that she's like cool sure
enough she has two of them frozen inside
because i needed a banana
so i put the frozen one in i was like
man this works perfect yeah
they get creamier when they're frozen
check this out
over four hours for you to finally drop
this knowledge
the secrets
okay good we grew my mom used to make
ice cream at home from frozen bananas
and just like literally put them through
the champion juicer freeze them put them
through the champion juicer
maybe add a little bit of like whatever
something to kind of like
put it up to the next level but like you
have like
homemade soft serve immediately so
the frozen bananas i vouch for i i'm
waiting for the plant-based mulk
yeah to come out i don't know if i
talked to you or pete about that but you
may have talked to both of us
[Music]
but that's that's what i do is for for
um after my workouts every day
my first meal that's my first meal is a
shake i kind of fast until after that
but i i do the the protein powder the
almond milk
the peanut butter just a healthy healthy
solid dollop
someone's going to stir off got the
frozen banana
and then i throw in i throw in some
chia seeds some pumpkin seeds
and flax seeds you guys make me feel
like the amateur is over
i don't know i go
i go milk dawn
that seems it's true it's a hearty shake
but then i'm like i'm good like i'm good
until like you know i have like an early
dinner
that's it yeah yeah that's kind of the
good thing you can use it for
many different reasons you know you can
do like a meal replacement
or just a supplementation for the
protein
you said you said protein and flex
double flexed your biceps
we can get these things at many places
if you're gonna be on the lookout for
any of these places you can get all this
stuff at first
wawa east coast what was only on the
east coast alright yes
okay wawa um origin main.com
jockofuel.com jacofuel.com kind of the
same
what do you call it trajectory yeah gold
vitamin c
i'm talking about and the vitamin c yes
sir by the way this is important
actually because shipping
is a problem right financially it can
cost a lot of money to ship something
here's the deal if you subscribe to any
of these items
shipping is free wow so we're trying to
look there's we're talking about tech
companies
there's obviously some big tech
companies out there that are hard to
compete with in fact
we you can't beat them join them we join
them it's fine you can get the stuff
there
because it's free shipping you know it's
like a it's like sort of a
that's a prime merry reason why people
might order from this particular place
which is cool
we're down we appreciate it 100 that's
fine but
if you wanted to just go straight to the
source but you didn't want to spend
money on shipping we got you covered
and it took us a while to figure out how
we could balance it if you subscribe
shipping's free on whatever you order so
that's kind of kind of huge
when you're talking about it's a very
strange
protein you're right yeah
and echo no offense to echo
sometimes he's not quite the pinnacle of
organization
when it comes i'm doing the best thing
so diplomatic i love it look again look
i prefaced it by saying no offense
so therefore you can't be offended yeah
hey i'm doing the best i can over here
i'm out of mulch by the way
there you go why aren't you subscribed
uh well you got issues
yeah is that issues nonetheless over
there flexing your biceps
nonetheless hey look this is where how
and where we can get all these
things also way to stay on the path
do jiu jitsu or martial arts martial
arts it's good for you let's go for your
mind body i'm glad you're being
diplomatic now well he's being
diplomatic and
like including being all inclusive of
all martial arts he's never said
anything like that before ever we talk
about doing martial arts
we're talking about jiu jitsu over here
on our side i think that's what we're
talking about you are correct but go
ahead
continue mr diplomatic thank you you've
improved his diplomacy already today
just hanging out with you he's got aloha
that's true normally this guy has no
aloha for other martial arts
oh it's like that you're here okay
everything's cool
well either way whatever martial arts
we're doing
i say do that stuff in the event of you
doing jiu jitsu
you're gonna need a gui and or rash
guard get those as well from origin how
much did you do
have you trained a little bit not a lot
i mean at the most
the most if you could i guess within the
family would be the army combatives oh
okay
just legit yeah the army combatives is a
great program
yeah developed by jiu jitsu guys exactly
i
i early on i guess the the the martial
art that i trained the most in was
was brazilian capoeira oh that's right i
was makes me laugh every time i hear you
pronouncing english words with a
brazilian portuguese accent
oh okay i was like yeah i know what
that's about although i talked
i said earlier starting off this program
that i'm very look i just say what i say
when it comes to you know brazilian
portuguese words like if you're going to
talk to me about oh you train capoeira
i'm coming at you
like a pro that's what we do overall now
well
and because of that i took summer
classes in brazilian portuguese in
hawaii like uh
like trying to learn the lang i was i
was getting fully immersed in the
culture and
and started to do a lot of a lot of my
friends who did capoeira also did jiu
jitsu and
met a lot there's a huge brazilian
community in hawaii because of surfing
and obviously most of them
do either capoeira and jiu jitsu as well
and uh but i just i was kind of um
consumed i was training like six hours a
day in capoeira and that was that was
i was starting to teach and i was doing
a bunch of stuff there
um but yeah so so the most time i spent
doing any kind of grappling was was army
combatives which was
fun well it's cool because now you're
going to be on the journey of jiu jitsu
we're going to get you a
gear yeah i want i really i i want to
learn and
i'm a big mixed martial arts fan i have
been for a long time
and yeah you went up and trained with
duke rufus right yeah that was an
incredible
surprise that i was not expecting but he
was there to train
um zhang wai lee and she was passing
through doing a publicity thing so i got
to meet her and
spar i use that word very generously
she's like come at me like kick me punch
like do something like
i don't know but it was like like
getting to hit some pads with duke was
freaking incredible
yeah and uh yeah it was awesome i've
cornered a
bunch of fighters at ufc and and
whenever duke rufus was there
he's just like such an awesome guy super
cool
super nice yeah super i mean obviously
he's a great trainer and everything but
i just remembered thinking this guy's
just freaking rad
yeah just totally totally and he makes
you know like he made us feel
just great and um but what i was gonna
say is the thing that i've always
appreciated most
most about mixed martial arts is you
know yeah there are guys who are
stronger in boxing or striking or
whatever but this
the strategery that goes into fighters
who have a very strong ground game
when you really watch it is i've
just incredible and that that's what
i've loved most about
uh the sport is the strategic thinking
that goes into like i'm gonna do this
and set you up for where i'm gonna put
you in you know six
moves later or oh yeah whatever so yeah
i'm
now now that i'm a little bit more free
um i i really do i've been telling my
husband this i want to i want to
learn we have connections yesterday in
the hawaiian islands
uh speaking of geese jiu jitsu geez and
jeans and boots you went to the factory
in maine right now i did
visited the origin factory in maine and
to say i was stoked is an understatement
and we made a little social media video
video about it and and you know
got some footage of pete showing us
around and talking about what they do
um brought the local media with us and
local media did a story on
on uh on origin but my husband will tell
you in the car ride
leaving i was so freaking stoked it was
it was
completely unexpected because i've had
the privilege of going and visiting a
number of you know local businesses and
shops
but the thing that really like
struck home for me like in a in a
visceral way
was awesome products
but the spirit
uh the spirit of
origin came through loud and clear
not just because pete's good at talking
about it
but because of what i experienced in the
people who work there
and the sense of pride and the sense of
of ownership of the thing that
says right there we get to do this
and and how deeply you all
have built the foundation of this
american business in the fabric of
america and that like i was like i
left there and i'm like i told pete i
was like um like
where do i sign up like how do i how do
i join this
because this is freaking amazing and i
talked about it and just shared
that's why i wanted to share um that
video and just the experience of being
able to go and visit
and it was not on the way like
farmington maine is on the way to
nowhere else i was going
and it was literally like i i called an
audible on my team and i'm like
yeah we're in maine and i'm gonna take a
two hour
like detour to go and visit because
the story of that you guys are sharing
of origin maine
is the story that needs to inspire
america
especially now in what what
we can do what we can do
here at home and that yes this is about
supporting a local business
it's about supporting america and
american jobs but it goes so much deeper
than that that yeah of course there are
challenges and there
as adversity and you know foreign trade
and
like all of these other things but just
like um you know pete talks about how he
started right in his freaking
backyard and built a factory because
there wasn't one
where there's a will there's a way and
when you're rooted in this
foundation of not just hey how can we
make a bunch of money
but how do how do you use business
as a means to
serve and have a positive impact in your
community in the lives of the people who
work there in
the customers who know like hey i'm not
just buying a product that's cool
i'm supporting a mission that's much
greater
than any one of us as individuals and
will have a much longer lasting
impact yeah if you were to take what you
just said
if you were if you and i were to look at
each other and say hey let's make a
business
and let's make you know let's make
clothes let's make apparel let's make
shoes
and let's make money the last thing we
would do to make money
is try and build a factory in america
correct and
source everything from america is
absolutely sad
and there's company upon company upon
company that their primary goal is to
make money
that's their primary goal it's not to
make a quality product
it's not to be innovative with their
products it's not to rebuild their
community
it's not to put money back into the
community it's not to not to bring
manufacturing back to america that's
that's not even on their radar
those are our primary goals now in order
to do that we do we have to make money
yes absolutely
and we will but that's not why we're
doing it
if we just wanted to make money we
wouldn't be there would be no factory
it'd be it'd be a sweat shop yeah
overseas that's what it would be
we're not going to do that we're never
going to do that and you'd be no
different than most of the others
that you know and and it would
you wouldn't be you origin wouldn't be
origin then ab absolutely
and to be quite frank with you money
could not drive me or inspire me
or motivate me one 100th
the amount that it does to know that
there's people
in that town yes that are working that
are have a career now
you know we're taking millennials and
teaching them
a a skill that was oh was so close to
being lost you saw them i did
millennials that their skills that were
i mean our
our guy lenny just died but he before he
died he was able to pass on his
knowledge
that can be passed on because it's saved
it's there yeah
we're we're there and it's
you also i was so stoked you know you
and i were texting back and forth and i
think i was trying to get you a pair of
boots i was like hey we'll get you some
boobs
yeah we had somebody deliver you boots
but for you to go up there was i was so
stoked that you could go up there and
you could see it
and and you know it's very cool too like
i'll hear joe rogan talking about origin
and even though he's not been there like
he knows
it's very cool when i saw when i heard
him talking about origen
and he was just talking about it with
some someone else that was was on his
show
when i heard him talking about it so
passionately
i realized this is people get it
you don't just you look it's awesome
when you go there and obviously when you
go there it's
visceral when you go there but even if
you don't go there
you know you know that some that pair of
jeans that you're wearing
those are those are american made the
hands that
harvested the cotton processed it every
step that's the amazing thing is
and i you know some of my some of my
friends in the military especially when
they got their stimulus checks
they're like i'm gonna make a choice
with this money and i'm gonna go
shopping
at origin because cool stuff but
i'm supporting america with these
dollars
and that that's the difference
and that's the impact and and i i i
loved sharing the story of my experience
there
to help inspire others who
may aspire to do something similar but
feel like the obstacles are too great
but but and whether it's business or
whatever i mean that the point is
the motivation and the spirit of getting
back to
not planning this but getting back to
our origins of who we are as a country
of
entrepreneurs and innovators and people
who are bringing different ideas to
to um and the pride
the pride uh that goes that goes along
with that origin usa
yeah originusa.com if you want to get
any stuff from there
it's made by americans for americans
it's true
also let me point your attention to
jockostore.com this is where you can
represent
there's on the path there you go so yeah
we have some
some stuff that we have is from origin
we got rash guards on there um also we
have hoodies and shirts and you know
discipline equals freedom this kind of
stuff i'm saying
if your seems to get uncomfortable and
you start talking about him
is it that obvious it is that obvious
there's a visible shift here
yeah in energy what's funny is it's kind
of like a complimentary relationship
because
like my comfort increases when his
discomfort
increases so it's like cool that's why
you can kind of sense
some pride when i talk about the store
store by the way anyway yes this will
include shirts
hoodies rash guards uh some hats on
there
some new stuff on there new design
coming out soon oh really i'll let you
know these are all things that happen
decentralized command like i'm not over
there pointing the finger and making
things happen that's echo charles
in his own little world well
it's our world we have a subscription
situation as well
if you want like a new type of design
kind of um
is that where the is that where the run
dmc t-shirt just came from yes
that was legit that's good
before they're done sometimes sometimes
there is a level
of decentralized command but i also
some people in the organization will say
occasionally need to get put in check
so there is sometimes but occasionally
these things slip by like he just made a
run the md
run dmc t-shirt but it says discipline
but it it's ds
what is it dsc pln yeah but it looks
like the old school run dmc yeah
t-shirt so it's freaking legit i
thought so too there's also ones like
the element you know the periodic table
yeah the element yeah so it's element d
and it has all the
the atomic weight 434 nice
layers anyway these are kind of offshoot
designs but they're cool
relevant and there's layers oh here's
the thing that's jacked up
now i just realized if you wanted that
run dmc
discipline shirt you can only get it if
you subscribe if you're a subscriber to
the shirt lock the shirt locker the
shirt locker of echo
it's true yeah once they're gone they're
gone that's so mad so limited
limited it's kind of a bummer yeah and
by the way it seems like
one person at this table does not have a
subscription to this
what's funny is i for real have a
subscription i for real don't
oh you were just jacked up brutal brutal
i thought you were calling me out by not
calling me out that's what i thought
oh but okay there's two people that
don't have a subscription apparently
dang that makes two of us i guess or one
of us whichever
either way maybe i have some extra oh
i'll hook you guys up oh
man that'd be great is that cool yeah
that'd be very nice
if you could hook me up with my own
stuff
uh speaking of subscription subscribe to
this podcast
wherever you subscribe to podcasts also
we have jocko unraveling
which we're about to record somewhere
this week awesome
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast and
by the way you also have another podcast
to subscribe to
which is called this is tulsi gabbard
this is tulsi gabbard it's actually up
already so i posted a trailer you can
you can
subscribe and follow now so that you can
know when we dropped the first
episode and follow on once
you can also join us at the underground
jockowunderground.com which i already
mentioned so i'm not going to go into a
big um
explanation but gotta have a contingency
plan
don't wanna act b don't wanna be
feeling the chains of
control yeah from
anyone not sponsors
not tech companies no one
we're so so we got to go underground yep
docker underground.com if you want to
help us out there
it costs eight dollars and 18 cents a
month
which is got layers to it yes sir we'll
talk about that offline
yep and look we're not if you can't
afford that
for whatever reason you're running into
some tough times right now there's covid
whatever
and you can't afford it order or or
email
assistance at jockowunderground.com and
we can get that taken care of
we have a youtube channel it's true
which has a lot of videos
on it the good ones i'm the assistant
director on the rest of them
it's echo solo you have a youtube
channel too
yeah tulsi gabbard you post we post all
kinds of stuff we'll be posting
we'll be posting the um uh the podcast
on there
as well but also just you know different
things that are happening i i
often record short videos kind of
weighing in on maybe issues of the day
or news or different things that are
coming forward and
more often than not bring a different
perspective
than one you're getting uh in the news
so
um yeah i post those uh across youtube
and across social media at tulsi gabbard
psychological warfare is an album you
did you know that i was an artist
tulsi i did not i mean recording a
recording artist
so if you want to get my album um and
it's the artist
is jocko okay and the the album is
called psychological warfare
and there's a bunch of tracks on there
that you can listen to whenever you need
them
is the wake up track one of them the
wake up track
apparently that was the sleep track
sweet dreams uh flipside canvas
flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer my
brother he makes all kinds of cool stuff
again american-made stuff that that is
the highest quality
puts all kinds of stuff that you can
hang on your wall to remind you of
the path got a bunch of books
uh i got a book called final spin which
is the novel
not out yet comes out in september i've
been tracking that
yeah it's pretty crazy i just got the
final
or i just did the final edits it's it's
freaking i was
my daughter my oldest daughter read it i
was like how can you review this
and so she read it and you know your
kids are always like
gonna be harsh critics or whatever and
my
i said oh you know she got done reading
it so you know how was it how did you
like it and so she starts going you know
i like this and i like that
and then she she got to a point and she
started because it's an emotional
situation she started to cry oh my god
this is not wall street this was
after a day after she read it she
started crying
and she was like and and then i was kind
of like oh
i go i guess that's a good judge she was
like just that that part so and i was
like okay
so it's very interesting so not the
this is it's just not a sob story but
it's uh you would want to write a book
that moves people
well i mean yeah i guess i guess if it's
not going to
have any impact or if it's going to have
an impact that's a good thing to make
people think
yeah and it's a it's it's definitely
even as i read it and i've read it now a
hundred times because i have to edit it
you know there's some parts where i'm
reading it and it's definitely
it's it's heavy it's heavy and it's got
some really funny parts too a lot of the
dialogue is really funny because
i you know it's reflective of kind of
the dialogue that i have with people
even though it's not about me
or is it i'm not sure it's open to
interpretation
yeah it's sort of an alternative
anyways the book is called final spin
and you can pre-order right now
if you want to get a first a dish yes if
you want to get a first a dish
order it now and look thi this is going
to be kind of a big deal to get the
first edition of the first novel
you know what i'm saying am i over
hyping that is the second
in the works this
this book will have no follow-on okay um
for various reasons it primarily
includes
it does conclude it is called final spin
it is not like
first spin so
it is called final spin but also i it's
it is
it is complete sure in my mind it's
complete and so
i don't want to carry the story on but
you have more novels than you
oh yeah i mean i got 14 novels that i
thought of during the last half an hour
yeah awesome yeah it's um unfortunate
for me it's always just
people say oh i don't know what to write
about oh my god i wish i had that
problem
so that's that final spin pre-order it
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol display equals freedom field
manual
way the warrior kid four field manual
that's out way the warrior kid one two
and three
mikey and the dragons i was listening to
i was listening to jordan peterson okay
yesterday and and he was just going off
about the dragons which is
sure a lot of what he does and
interestingly
enough i was like sounds like this book
called mikey and the dragons
so check that one out about face
by david hackworth there's a forward by
me
and tulsi you've i just got it in the
mail
a couple of days before i left hawaii
and i have read
your forward okay and i'm just starting
what's the impression starting
the book um how
incredibly impactful this book and this
man has been on your life as a person
but the thing that really um
like spoke to me was how this was kind
of
um your go-to reference to help guide
you through difficult leadership
choices decisions challenges that you
face in some of the most difficult
environments i.e being
in at war and and that you've never met
the man
and that was um that came through
very clear kind of your gratitude to
him um in having this
this book that provided you with that
place where you could find the answers
that you couldn't find anywhere else or
help you
see things in a different way that you
wouldn't have seen otherwise
through his experiences and how he
handled things or his perspective
and then the the maybe the most
important thing was
that all of that came from the foremost
concern being care
for your guys his soldiers
your seals soldiers who you were
people who um you were responsible for
and uh i i thought that was a really
cool thing for me to come out
i've only heard you talk about it but to
come at this book
and i'm really looking forward to re
continuing to read it but to see
that bridge in time and that that and
conflicts and wars
between a guy who served in vietnam and
was a leader of soldiers in vietnam to
you
and the experience that you had as a
leader serving in iraq
and how there was such um
powerful connection between two
different leaders and two different wars
and different places in different times
that that's not something i've really
heard of
before
it's weird because i as i read that book
have you ever seen the movie the i think
it's called the 13th warrior
have you ever heard of this movie tom
cruise no
so anyways it's based on it's based on a
book
by michael crichton and i can't remember
the name of the book that it's based
upon
but it's about this arabic
person who gets somehow mixed up in with
the vikings
and there's a great scene and that the
arabic
guy is played by some famous actor
god i can't think of it echo trump
really wishes
but they show they did they do this
scene where he's learning
to speak norwegian or whatever old norse
whatever language you're speaking
and the way that they cut it up they're
speaking
norwegian and then every once in a while
an english word pops in
which would have been an arabic movie or
arabic word but it's a
it's a it's an english speaking movie so
every once in a while
an uh an english word will pop in so
it's like
a mother mother
tree and so and he starts picking up and
it's probably a two minute scene
where by the end all the words are in
english
the reason i'm telling you this is
because as you were as you were talking
about the book about face
i feel like each time i read it like a
little because it's not a book about
leadership and you know you mentioned
leadership it's not a book about
leadership
it's a book about a guy's life but it's
like as each time i read it
a little leadership thing would come
through
and then a little bit more and then a
little bit more and eventually the whole
thing i realized this whole thing is
just about leadership and it's about how
to take care of your troops and do the
mission and
it's it's i just had that thought as you
were
as you were describing the correlations
between
what he lived through and what i lived
through which by the way
just for the record not even close he
was in
korea in vietnam he's the he had three
distinguished service crosses
nine silver i mean just totally
different
but good book to check out
the closest thing that i can relate to
in my time
in the military is you mentioned band of
brothers earlier
and i was a brand new maybe i was an e3
or an e4 by that point
but i picked up the book band of
brothers
before ever watching the the mini series
i don't even know if it was made at that
time yet
but uh i was brand new in the national
guard i started reading the book just as
we were about to go and do an annual
training at fort indian town gap in
pennsylvania
and i'm reading the book i like can't
put it down we go there we're there for
10 days or two weeks or whatever it was
on the plane going back to hawaii and i
finished the book
and at the end of the book it says
dick winters currently resides in fort
indian town gap
pennsylvania where he lives with his
wife yeah and i'm just like
why didn't i finish this two days
earlier i would have
definitely gone and knocked on this man
and he was still alive at the time
um that was but but i've you know gone
on
and watched i mean i've watched this
year i don't even know how many times
i've watched it
um in ocs we had to write essays on
different episodes
from a leadership perspective leadership
lessons good and bad
and really analyzed um each episode of
that and
and so that's that's one and that's the
only kind of closest thing i can relate
to we're going back
and looking at him and his leadership
and
i always forget the guy's name but the
guy who's ross in france
thank you um his his uh
flawed leadership i would say and the
lessons learned from that and as a
specialist then and then a brand new
lieutenant i
i have often gone back to those
leadership lessons including the ones of
um
you know some of the uh oh gosh i'm
forgetting the name now
some of the enlisted characters yep and
uh one that was played by donnie
wahlberg
um one of the main e6's and uh
and that was i had a chance to meet
donnie wahlberg at a veterans event and
like i don't i don't really care about
celebrities in general but i saw he was
there i'm like
i need to go speak to this person about
band of brothers
and uh it was it was really cool he's a
huge huge huge supporter of veterans
i was on um a show called billions
you were yeah and the the
one of the main characters in billions a
guy named axelrod
uh yeah is uh he also played dick
winners he is forever dick winners in my
mind i don't care
like he was in homeland too like yeah
whatever you're dick winners
but we you know he we were sitting
around and talking and
and he said something along the lines of
like oh you know i was in something
called banner brothers i'm like
yeah i kind of know that i'm well aware
yeah
and so we talked a bunch about it it was
it was interesting because
in those i've never done any like
hollywood
things before i was like
yeah he likes to throw that at me well
when you do it
you film the same thing
10 times if not more so
like there's a scene where we're waking
a guy up in bed
and there's me and
axe and wags have you watched billions
before i've only seen one or two
okay really it's a freaking fantastic
show okay so
me axe wires three characters and so
we're waking a guy up
and the first time we film it is like
they're filming all three of us and we
deliver the lines
and then you stop and then they reset up
all the cameras and then they
do it again but they're just filming me
and then they reset up the cameras and
they do it again they're just filming
wags and then they refill it again
they're just filming action and then
they refill it again they're just
filming the girl in bed then they refill
it again
and then they do it from behind us and
they do it so it ends up you end up
doing this thing
10 times 15 times 20 and by the way if
someone messes up
doing it again so
i was talking to him and i said how in
god's name did you film like a battle
scene yeah
how the hell did you do that and he he
said it's totally different because
there's basically guys running around
with cameras
and they do it one freaking time and
they just have to get it right
and they're running through it because
explosions are going off and like a
building is going to get destroyed
and it's only going to get one take yeah
so that was pretty interesting no
pressure
right as an actor not only because
of that just the the logistics of it but
like
the history and what you're doing and
who you're representing like my gosh
i can't i can't imagine he um so if
someone messes up the director comes and
like talks to him
right he just reprimanded like i'm
serious so
if someone any maybe he doesn't mess up
but maybe he's not putting the right
right stank on it right you know what
i'm saying like you're technically too
little
you know you're being too emotional and
so it happened
i didn't really i didn't know any of
this were you playing
a military person yourself i i had a
real stretch of a role
i played me okay all right yeah so i
played me and i was
whatever trying to i was trying to help
a guy win a smoker's
fight a boxing match and we're training
him
um but if you mess up
or you don't put enough or you put a
little too much or whatever the the
director
actually the first the assistant
director is going to come and give you a
little nudge in the right direction hey
that was a little
you know don't be so loud uh you know
you're too emotional
this isn't supposed to be funny or
whatever something like that and so this
actually happened to me i don't know if
i'm not supposed to talk about stuff
like this maybe it's off limits
but it's done it's fine it happened to
one of the other actors
we were doing is just me and one other
actor in a scene
and we do it and i'm just doing what i
do so
honestly it's pretty if i have to get
talked to it's a problem because i'm
just being myself right
so i'm doing what i'm doing and
the the assistant director comes down
first and it's like hey you know what
you might want to back that down a
little bit not talking to me but talk to
the other guy
and and he's like what are we going to
do he said yeah we're going to do it
again which is kind of a big deal like
it's not it's not a small thing right
we're actually because i remember saying
wait are we going to have to shoot this
again he goes yeah we're going to shoot
it again
so it's kind of so
i realized that this was kind of a thing
if you and then if you continue to mess
up then it's not just the assistant
director
if the director is going to come down
and try and give you you know whatever
what do they give you
[Music]
and so i'm watching this going dude i
don't want none of this and so i
remember
one time uh uh so now it's me
axe and wax and they're the main guys
and these guys and i didn't know
anything about anything right
but this is a very popular show and it's
an incredibly well-written show
the the writers i know the writers now
and they're just
so good and you understand so anyways
they're we do a take
right hollywood we do it and like
you can hear you can hear like radios
like you can hear something
and you so now all you realize someone
messed up right
and then they come walking up and uh
and he comes walking up you can he's
behind us the director he pulls one of
the other guys aside you know blah blah
blah and i was like and i said
axe i was like bro i thought he was
coming for me
even the pros don't like
get the talking too so there you go um
other books extreme ownership first book
i wrote wrote about leadership
and then the dichotomy of leadership
echelon front leadership consultancy
we solve problems through leadership go
to salonfront.com if you want us to come
to your company and help we got ef
online it's an
online leadership training platform to
get your whole
organization aligned not just a line
towards a common goal but more important
aligned in how they are going to lead
go to efonline.com for that we got the
muster
2021 a bunch of different dates we're
going to be coming around the country
check extreme ownership.com if you want
to come to one of those they've all sold
out
every time we've done one these are
going to sell out too so check it early
we've got
ef battlefield which is we've done one
so far we're doing another one
we go out and we walk the grounds of
the battlefield at gettysburg oh yeah
and you we sit there we talk through the
decisions that were made we talk about
general lee
and longstreet and ap hill and and
stewart and mead and hancock and
reynolds and
and and joshua chamberlain from maine
we we talked through with their
personalities
decisions that got made egos that got
involved hesitation
being overly aggressive not being
aggressive enough we talk throughout so
many
lessons to learn and this is a little
tiny group of people
there's 35 people that we bring to this
event
it's all day long um me the rest of the
echelon
of quite a few of the echelon front
instructors walk in the battlefield we
do dinner we're going to do a q
a it's we will answer whatever questions
you have and we will all
learn about these lessons so if you want
to go to that go to godaddlefront.com
events to check that out did you take a
note there
i did um highly highly recommend i've
had the opportunity to do that
a few times one of which while i was
um well we went we went to the
battlefield of chickamauga
when i was in ocs and we did that as a
class
incredible bringing history to life and
making it relevant especially
from a leadership perspective that
applies whether you're in the military
or not
but something i found out pretty cool
in the last year or so i was asked to be
on this
show on pbs called finding your roots
and it's a show that features different
people
in in my episode they also had paul ryan
and marco rubio but you know like
oprah they've had different people on
and and they dig
into your genealogy and find stories
about
your roots where you come from who you
come from and
i found out that
one of my ancestors on my mother's side
of the family
was 39 40 years old when he volunteered
to serve in the union
army and that
he it was the and they had the
documentation there
of one of those battlefields
where he fought that i had been to
previously and visited
and walked through and it was the most
like it was the most incredible thing on
on many levels
to see like this guy gave up his life
to go and and fight for what he believed
in
and that i had generations later
not only physically walked through that
battlefield where he was
but also chose a similar path
um with my life and so
um it was just it was it was and i've
gone back to gettysburg a few times
since
and every single time i go
um it's an incredibly powerful
experience
incredibly powerful and to go to the
place where of course lincoln
delivered the gettysburg address yeah
yeah it's when when because we basically
we spend
the two days walking and then we we when
we wrap it up and you kind of
now you clearly know and you've seen
the low ground the high ground the trees
the buildings
and you're walking where thousands of
men
were killed yeah
it's it it's just it's just unbelievable
it's an unbelievable event it's an
unbelievable place
and it's an incredible way to learn and
solidify those so
that's ef echelonfront.com
events if you want to go um it's in
april so
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families
then check out mark lee's mom she's got
a
in a charity organization mama lee if
you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my imposing
interrogations
or you want more of echo's quiet
questions
and pop culture commentary pop culture
commentary
i just so whenever i'm
giving echo a hard time if it's a pretty
good one
then he'll say to me like you're real
happy with yourself aren't you you're
really enjoying yourself aren't you
you really enjoyed yourself aren't you
you think you're good don't you
and i that's how i know i'm kind of
getting there
and as i got as when we got here today
as i got out of the car
i was i was responding to twitter or
instagram
and i had just made a comment and i got
out of the car and said hey you know
sometimes you say that to me
because someone had said the the last
woman that was on holly mckay
someone had said oh did she does she
stay for the support section
meaning what we've dragged you into for
the past freaking hour
and i said uh no
she was able to withstand you know isis
interrogations but she couldn't hang
with echo charles and the support so
there you go yeah he's very very happy
with that one good sense that the pride
and the tone of the the comment there
you go admittedly so
guilty uh if you want more of us you
can't you then then you can find us on
the interweb
and and that's including tulsi's way
tulsi as well
at tulsi gabbard echo is at echo charles
and i am at jonko willink echo charles
you got anything else
are you running for president again ever
or even possibly
do you think i don't know i'm not
thinking about it at all
if you did would you ask about aliens
remember how who
someone asked about aliens right i think
so i think it was like clinton or
something
um it's not on the top of my list i
understand
put it that way there you go did i say
something about echo's questions earlier
he saved the best for last point what's
funny is when i first met you or
whatever i was like
i don't think i ever met anyone that ran
for president before
so then you know how you kind of think
like what would i ask and then
for some reason this is it what's this
yeah this is the moment yeah
all the rest of the stuff is like okay
whatever but yeah
oh man gotcha i have nothing else but
thank you
awesome tulsi thank you any closing
thoughts
i um it's great to be here and
we've covered a lot and there's a lot
more to come
yeah awesome well um
obviously thanks for coming on i know we
try to make this happen for a little bit
i'm glad you could kind of
finally get on here and and thanks for
your service
in the united states government of
course but
also obviously thanks for your service
as a soldier as a leader
thanks for putting your life on hold
and your life at risk to defend
the freedoms and the way of
life that we hold sacred
and the same goes to the rest of the
military personnel out there
around the world
on those forgotten barricades on the
front lines of freedom thank
you for defending us and to our police
and law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers and border patrol
and secret service and all the first
responders
thank you for defending us as well
here at home and to everyone else out
there
well for one thing ask yourself
is today the day
is today the day and
live your life thinking that today could
be
the day and that means
remember some of that aloha spirit
that tulsi talks about
treat people with aloha treat them with
respect and compassion and try and help
out other people
and you do that you do all those things
by first
putting your own ego in check
listen more than you talk
praise more than you punish
stand up for what you believe in while
respecting
other people's beliefs too and remember
always remember that we
are stronger together
and until next time this is tulsi and
echo
and jocko out